narcissism is not arrogance narcissism
is the opposite of arrogance there is
such a deep sense of inadequacy and
incompetence in the self that the
defensive structure around that becomes
dominated by a rocket fueled Envy
the following is a conversation with
Paul Conte a psychiatrist and a
brilliant scholar of human nature my
friend Andrew huberman told me that Paul
and I absolutely must meet and talk not
just about the topic of trauma which
Paul wrote an amazing book about but
broadly about human nature about
narcissism sociopathy psychopathy good
and evil hate and love happiness and
envy as usual Andrew was right this was
a fascinating conversation as the old
meme goes One does not simply doubt the
advice of Andrew huberman
allow me to also quickly mention that I
disagree with Paul a bunch in this
episode as I do in other episodes even
with experts in part for fun and in part
because I think the tension of ideas and
conversation is what creates insights
and wisdom my goal is to always
empathize understand and explore ideas
of the person sitting across from me
this agreement is just one of the ways I
think it's fun to do just that as long
as I do so from a place of curiosity and
compassion
this is a Lex Friedman podcast to
support it please check out our sponsors
in the description and now dear friends
here's Paul Conti
do you see Psychiatry as fundamentally a
study of the human mind and not just a
set of tools for treating psychological
maladies absolutely I think Psychiatry
is our best way to understand who we are
as people I mean it looks at our biology
you know how does our brain work how
does it connect the parts with one
another how does the chemistry in it
work it's a very foundational aspects of
who we are and then it manifests as
psychology what do we think what do we
feel what are our strivings what are our
fears so yeah I think Psychiatry
provides tools that we can use to help
each other but those tools come through
it being a discipline of understanding
so with every patient you see with every
mind you explore are you picking up a
deeper understanding of the human mind
I think I'm trying to I think we should
learn we should be able to take
something away from everything we do you
know every interaction to some small
degree every conversation if it doesn't
have to be a patient just anywhere at
Starbucks getting a coffee you can learn
something from that little experience
yeah even if you just reinforce sort of
gentle kindness and gratitude and and
decent human interaction there's a
reinforcement of that that even if we
don't take away memories or lessons so
to speak we can reinforce who we choose
to be
so understanding ourselves from those
interactions too not just the general
sort of philosophical human mind but
understanding our own mind
introspect on how our own mind works
yeah everything we understand about
anyone or anything else is coming
through here right so yeah so we're
understanding others where we're also
understanding ourselves it's all feeding
through US yeah yeah but it's a tricky
thing to step away and look at your mind
and understand that it's just a machine
and you can kind of control the way the
machine processes the external
environment and the way that machine
converts the things it perceives into
actual emotions like how it interprets
the things it perceives you just sort of
step away and analyze it in that way and
then you can control it you can you can
oil the machine you can control how it
actually interprets the Perceptions in
order to generate positive emotions and
be like a what is it like a mechanic
for the for the gears in the machine
I mean I think to some degree to some
degree of it the difference I think at
least is I understand I think of
machines as not being inscrutable right
that that if there's enough study
there's enough Acumen applied that we
can understand whatever it is we're
trying to to figure out whereas part of
understanding ourselves is understanding
that there are things we can't
understand and I think that's that's
indispensably important I think to
health and happiness and also to having
enough humility to see how people can be
different from us how we can be
different from ourselves at times so
knowing that we don't know a lot and
having some idea of what that might be I
I think is an indispensable part of the
process which I think is different from
machines I think yeah the machines
you're basically saying machines
generally because they're engineered
from a design they're usually going to
be simpler therefore understandable and
you're saying the complexity of the
human mind is uh
at least from our perspective nearly
infinite
is there a meta phenomena what sometimes
gets described as sort of levels of
emergence where at increasing levels of
complexity you have novelty evolved that
you that you can't predict from from
lower levels of complexity like for
example atoms to molecules you know it's
just one example I I think uh neurons to
Consciousness Consciousness to culture
right that there are meta phenomena that
separate from the phenomenon from the
phenomena underneath of them and and
therefore by adding an entire aspect of
novelty so I I think we are
I mean I really think this is true that
we are all infinitely fascinating
because of these levels of emergence of
novelty that are inscrutable because you
can't predict from one level to the next
or understand fully are what make us and
not just us but I think sentient
creatures right human beings right but
sentient creatures inestimably more
interesting than than creatures that
aren't as sentient and and I don't know
I think when when we think about machine
learning and artificial intelligence I
think it's that that we're trying to
create levels of emergence that now we
don't fully understand anymore which I
guess is both exciting and maybe scary
too
yeah so he started the physics of atoms
uh quantum mechanics going to chemistry
going to biology
from the biology you have the functional
phenomena especially as manifested in
the human brain and then multiple brains
connecting together through
Consciousness intelligence creates
civilizations it's pretty interesting
where do you think the magic is at which
layer of the cake every layer because
every time you emerge from one thing to
another I see it as an analog like the
concept of the dialectic right where I
think it was Hegel right who who
realized
um hey when you when you have like thing
a and thing B and they're complicated
and they come together you know you
don't get a hybrid of A and B right you
know you you end up getting something
that's new that's novel and and I think
that describes to some degree that like
what emergence is except there's
there's a whole new and it's Universe of
novelty right that that comes at each
layer of emergence that allows infinite
possibilities that weren't possible
before and I think that's why we're so
complicated that we're our functional
Neuroscience right which I think is
psychology right our ability to think
about ourselves about others to be
reflective is sitting on top of so many
layers of emergence like the idea of
standing on the shoulders of giants that
we're you know each of us our
Consciousness is standing on the
shoulder of a giant of many many many
levels of emergence of novelty so many
of which we don't understand I mean
about subatomic particles everything
that that quantum physics means you know
when when does time become important
right as opposed to things happening
outside of time and outside of space
when do we slot into one temporal
perspective and then the complexity just
I think grows and grows and grows yeah
the interesting word you use is novelty
if true this really blows my mind in
some uh either shallow or deep sense it
is true I'm trying to figure that out I
don't know if you know something about
cellular automata is this very simple
mathematical objects where you have
rules that govern each individual little
cell and they interact locally and that
you know you understand the very simple
operations those individual cells but
add another layer of abstraction when
you just kind of zoom out with blurry
vision these uh meta objects starts
appearing that function you could build
a touring machine where they can build
an arbitrary complexity of of compute of
uh of computation on top of this kind of
very simple object yes it's an
interesting question whether
that was always there
the atoms
somehow know about love right like about
Consciousness
about war and violence and evil and hate
and all that that's already Laden in the
possibility of that the capacity for
that it's already in the atoms it's
already in the physics it's already in
them
in in all the different chemistry and it
builds up and it's like even the origin
of life
still a mystery that's that's known
that's in the physics that's known to
the universe the basic uh background
physics in the universe
because if that's not the case
where does that come from where's that
magic
and how many layers can the cake
possibly have how many are we gonna keep
building if it's all if there's if we're
constantly through this process of
abstraction of adding a layer to the
cake adding novel things
like where's the ceiling
as we expand out into the cosmos if we
successfully can do that we're going to
keep building like more miraculous
complex objects and then the brain is
just like a middle layer
thing we tend to think of ourselves as
truly truly special manifestations of
what's possible in the universe but
maybe we're just like the basic like
tiny building block of something much
much bigger we're in the early days of
being a brick and a very large building
sure look I think that's entirely
possible I mean I think the only
emergent thing so to speak that that we
build is culture right the aggregation
of us so you have individual human Minds
which are entirely unique even the fact
that time is different for you and me
right it may be by Pico seconds right
but we can engage because our our
perceptions of time are parallel enough
they're close enough right that we can
share a reality right but we're all
living in a different dimension of time
right I mean we know that right so we're
unique in that way and then the Unique
Individuals that we are just like the
cells right start to create not just one
thing not just a culture but culture on
top of our individuality right there our
uniqueness our even dimensional
uniqueness of of time and experience and
and Consciousness so we create cultures
on top of us but what could be Beyond
culture right and and what is different
from us either on underlying levels like
you know like quantum physics or
chemistry or biology or entirely
different and unconceived I think is
it's an immense question and I think
it's one that should create humility in
us right that look look how much we
don't know and then how Reckless we are
with ourselves with our Resources with
with human life and and I think there
it's I I it's important to say I mean
you think about how entropy rules
the universe around us I mean how over
selected are we how many not just
hundreds or thousands of times but how
many millions of times does there have
to be a selection Branch point before we
get into a sort of Eddie pool of counter
entropy right where you can begin to
create
right which which I think is why I say
okay the the atoms know about love right
the the the fact that anything is being
created right means there's this over
selection for counter entropy where
there can be a building of Greater
complexity of ultimately of novelty and
we don't often think about that of of
how far removed we are maybe light years
so to speak uh from any other location
temporally physically in the universe
where this could happen and we don't
think about what does that
mean everything that you said love
everything is uh uh counter entropy goes
against the way
uh the basic physics of the universe so
maybe actually the atoms really don't
like what we're doing they want us to
stop they've been trying really hard to
stop and despite that we somehow uh
started this whole bacteria thing for
for like a billion years and now we're
hearing it I give it kind of the other
way I don't think there's any purpose to
purposelessness right so so why would
anything be here if we if the drive
weren't towards
creativity right if the drive warrant
towards those subatomic particles not
being nothingness that blips in and out
of existence right like we think is
going on in empty space you know for
light years upon light years right but
is
is there a design either natural or
intentional for
um a schema right a scenario that allows
for the incredibly rare but not
non-existent Eddie pool of counter
entropy where good can happen right
where creativity can happen where
ultimately something can grow something
novel can happen there's no novelty in
the vastness of space even though
there's not nothing there there's
novelty here because I think the the
layers of uh of emergence start stacking
very very very high when we're in the a
place of counter entropy which then
could provide even thoughts about like
good and evil right the idea that
creating that preserving is good right
it's what we build upon it's how we get
to the Eddie pool of counter entropy
right so then destruction is not good
you know what what good comes of
aggression and destruction right you
know unless we're protecting we can
think of of outlying cases but just
think in general concepts right the
destruction destroys it brings us
towards a state of entropy towards a
state of nothingness whereas goodness
commonality
um collaboration right
nurturing right brings
novelty it brings new existence into the
universe and I think we don't we don't
think about that we're in the middle of
something so vast and built on top of so
many layers and I think it leads us to
be Cavalier you know with with human
life including often our own
so you think this there's a underlying
creative force of the universe that uh
that might even have a kind of
built-in morality to it where
creating is better than destroying
and then that somehow maps on onto our
society where we kind of try to figure
out what that actually means in terms of
Good and Evil so there that's some
something is there like that but it's
like but it has to be
it's like so nice it's so perfect
because it's rare
is sufficiently rare where we have our
own space like you can like close the
door and it's like I need to be alone
right now as our human civilization to
work on my thing so it's sufficiently
rare that there's not other alien
civilizations they're just like
constantly knocking on our door
destroying us
um but it still exists that's weird
right right it's so fantastically
improbable yeah that I think we should
be very respectful of it and I think you
said there's a creative force that
values creativity yes things to be well
sure if it's a creative Force right it's
existence its ability to exist and to
create
comes from something other than entropy
right something other than so much
dispersion that there's nothingness
right so so the creative force will
value
the sanctity of things right you know
keeping things together not destroying
things right building novelty including
novelty of knowledge novelty of
sentience I mean it fits with the idea
that we're not nothing that that's
incredibly improbable and that there are
these many many layers of emergence that
we're standing upon and I think it tells
us something that we're not doing
ourselves a service to ignore right it's
not just a jump to saying oh there's a
religious answer to everything he says
no it's saying
science isn't a God either right so if
we if we if we think of science as a
tool and not as an endpoint in and of
itself what is the science telling us
like I remember showing up at medical
school and it really is true I mean I
knew so little about the human body I'd
only been in hospitals to visit people
I've taken pre-med classes but sort of
intensely at once after I didn't take
any and I was working in business I I
knew next to nothing and and I had this
idea that was so naive in retrospect
that I was going to learn so much right
I was going to answer these questions
because I was going what's going on in
the body what are these organs doing
what are these cells and what I learned
was
there was so much more that was amazing
and mysterious and seemingly impossible
like even how a cell functions right
like what is going on inside of a cell
the transport mechanisms and energy
functions and diffusion functions and
then you can go down to smaller levels
than that but when you come back out and
you say how all those cells make a
kidney it's not
explanatory you know I remember asking
the OB who had delivered my first child
right I was so amazed and I asked him
like what do you think like what do you
know you do this right you you're seeing
this life created and you know and his
thought was nothing where I just marvel
you know I mean I get to do this but I
just marvel at it and I think the more
we know
about us the more we respectfully Marvel
and we should do that we should
proactively Marvel at every aspect
at every layer
uh that uh where the novelty emerges yes
we'd be a lot less likely to say hey I
don't like you because of something
whatever it is you know race religion
culture sexuality gender identity
whatever it is you know oh I want to say
I want rights that you don't have right
or I want what you have right I mean
there's so much of this and I understand
it's driven by scarcity and by human
insecurity and envy and all of these
things that I think could drive us
towards destruction but all of that
recklessness comes from
not having this initial appreciation and
respect that you're referring to and
just marveling at like wow okay we're
here that's amazing let's start with
that
but if we Marvel at this whole thing
the human project The Human Condition
the all the different kinds of human
beings that are possible
what do you then make of that some
humans do evil onto the world
first of all are all human beings
capable of evil if we're in the process
now we've got a little bit of momentum
in terms of marveling yeah the layers of
the cake uh should we also Marvel at the
capacity for evil in all of us yeah is
that capacity there I believe that it is
yes so what do we understand about the
psychology of evil where does that
originate in the human mind is it there
in the new biology is it there in the
environment in the upbringing can I
clarify first I think the capacity for
evil I do believe is in all of us
there's a difference between enacting
evil and and a sort of preset followed
developed plan of evil right I don't
believe that all of us are capable of
doing
what the people who perpetrate the most
evil do right but I do believe that
we're capable of of perpetrating evil
right and the the thought one thought
would be that there are drives in US I
mean there certainly seem to be drives
in US towards survival towards
gratification uh in some ways towards
pleasure and that can get very
complicated because pleasure inside can
be relief of distress so if I feel very
badly about myself and I can feel a
little better about myself by making you
feel worse about yourself right which
that plays out in a lot of human beings
is is that an indirect way of bringing
pleasure right so it gets very
complicated what's going on inside of us
and sometimes the perpetration of evil
things can be through misunderstandings
anger impulsivity I mean the things that
we can that we can have in Us and other
times there can be there can be other
things going on which are through the
lens of unhealthy human psychology so
for example the psychology of Envy which
I think drives the Lion's Share of the
orchestrated evil right there's a
difference between impulsive reflexive
evil and highly orchestrated evil which
I think is driven by
Envy highly orchestrated evil are we
talking about a skilled societies like
totalitarianism so if we're thinking
about about somebody like Hitler so as
at scale
orchestration of evil Envy driving that
so I mean that's really interesting to
to think about I'd love to hear more
about it so some of it there might be
some psychological forces that are in
tension
with each other so one is
if you look at somebody like Hitler
it's difficult to know what was going on
in his mind but it's possible to imagine
if you just look at dictator's thought
history that he thought he was doing
good not just for himself but for the
people he believed have value so one way
you can have what you can achieve what
we consider is evil
is uh by devaluing some group of people
and uh that could be all group of people
so it could have sort of a narcissistic
type of idea that you basically don't
care about other human beings that's one
Envy is different I mean maybe they can
collaborate together uh or even uh like
you mentioned you can actually enjoy
doing bad to others that's almost like
different because if if all it is is
like narcissism uh you disregard you
don't care what how others feel then you
can just have make cold calculated
military almost economic decisions and
you don't care if a million people die
here or there but if you actually enjoy
some aspect of that or there is like a
resentment that fuels it it's not just
cold calculation it's like fueled by
some kind of personal or uh cultural
resentment I think it's all fueled by
that you think so I think it's all field
but I think the idea that say Hitler
thought he was doing good good right it
is like that is such a thin facade that
it flies away like a handkerchief in a
hurricane right that
okay yeah I think that's wow that's
beautiful yeah it's it's built upon like
it says I'll explain logical lies right
because people can build lies upon
specious logic right so the idea that
okay I am doing good because I believe
that this
um ethnicity of people is good and this
is bad and now I'm going to do this and
I'm going to make the world different
and it's going to bring better to the
world and now I'm raising armies and I'm
building concentration camps and I think
like this is all in the service of good
is I don't I don't think anyone ever
thinks that right or they they think
that but with because they're living in
the surface patina right like they're
not allowing the hurricane in that blows
away the handkerchief and says like this
is all this is all this is all evil
right I mean how do you decide that some
group of people is good and some is bad
and like what what is it that you take
upon yourself to to to play God or make
decisions about the world and I think
what really is going on is people are
not doing that right there's something
cobbled together to say like why this is
right and this is okay right and this is
even good right but it is all
a lie right it's a lie that's adorning
the the what I believe is the fact I
believe that what's going on is the
gratification of Envy inside of the
person and whether someone says oh I
think this is good and it's okay if a
million people die or I'm going to enjoy
that a million people die I think is the
same I think the the enjoyment the
gratification of the orchestrated evil
is there and that it all comes from
vulnerability and insecurity it all
comes from deficits in the sense of self
right I'm gonna have to process that
my my my slow Penny and PC is processing
that so Envy underlies all of it the
psychological concept of envy what is
that
I keep putting myself in the mind of
Hitler I guess that that has nothing to
do it doesn't have to do with uh Jews or
Slavic people does it have to do with
specific amorphous
other
in his mind that he's envious of I think
it has all to do with him
all to do with him there's not a love of
the people with whom he Allied or even a
sense of the people who he persecuted
were worse than him it's all projections
out of what was going on inside of him
which was an intense sense of inadequacy
a rage at being someone he perceived as
lesser than that's the difference
between so we can define words in
different ways even within psychology
but let's say we take the definition
here of sort of jealousy as being sort
of benign right the idea that oh I might
see something that you have that I don't
and I might think I'd like that maybe
I'll work harder to get it right or
maybe I can't get it maybe it's that
you're younger than I am they say okay
you know okay you know you have that and
I don't I mean I have other things too
I'm okay anyway but I might want those
things but it's very benign the jealousy
I'd like to be younger I'd like to be
richer whatever it is that we people
think right
but it's just a thought and it's a
thought that can result in strivings or
acceptance right it's very very
different it's completely different than
Envy which is destructive it's the
thought of I see something that you have
that I don't have right and instead of
me working for it or accepting that I
don't have it what I'd like to do then
is bring you down
take you down to where I am and then
I'll feel better right because from the
perspective of Envy it is all relative
those jealousy a kind of is about
because he said completely different but
it's jealousy potentially like a gateway
drug to Envy like does it does it like
is it a slippery slope I think no I
think that jealousy is a natural just
part of the human phenomenon that we go
through life and we see like oh I'd like
to have I think it's probably part of
our incentives right if you know if if
I'm Farming and I have one row of crops
and I look over and I see that you're
working harder and you have two and I'd
like to have two that can make me work
harder to have too you don't think it's
slippery slope from one to the other to
at first you're like I'd like to work
harder but then you keep failing and the
weather sucks and you keep failing and
the other person becomes more successful
plus he's got a new hot wife now there's
a nice tractor uh does it feel this all
working and then you get this idea that
you know what I'm gonna steal all this
stuff I'm gonna murder him
and that you know don't you think that's
just like a leap no I actually think
it's the same phenomena no no because
but I think there are things that are in
us as humans right so so the things are
just by being human like we can for
example feel we can feel compassion
right we can feel interest right we can
feel jealousy in in that benign sense
like it's all part of just being human
if we if we start going from hey you
have more crops than I have and and you
know that seems like actually have a
better life in a lot of ways than I have
I'm gonna kill you that that's not that
is not a progression of something benign
right that is but wait wait a minute but
there is a human leap of the same thing
isn't it is because you're drawing a
line stuff you're saying like this is
the this human stuff it's regular life
it's benign
but it feels like this benign thing is
just a low magnitude thing
version of the thing that's not benign
because there's there's probably a gray
area where it stops being put like
jealousy you can have like healthy gel
so you can have a little bit slightly
unhealthy there's a that's I think
Jealous Guy this John Lennon song that I
love is just beautiful I mean there's
like this jealousy inside relationships
can make you feel like uh you know take
your minds in all kinds of silly
directions and it's crazy but like it
feels like that that's an extra neighbor
to like being really crazy and toxic and
all that kind of stuff inside
relationships and then that feels like a
next door neighbor it's like an
apartment building that feels like a
next door neighbor uh that eventually
gets to Hitler with uh with envy and
resentment of entire population of
people you're right that there's a
causal yeah there can be a causal chain
right like if I'm not feeling jealous
maybe I won't ever feel envious right so
so you can see okay so it can kind of
lead to it can open gates to huh like
how much do I dislike that you have
things that I don't have right so yes in
that sense but and I think this Supply
that I think is so important that I
think there is a disjunction right it's
if there's an asymptotic shift right
from one thing to another because if you
speak in my language mathematically yeah
yeah yes that that's it's a way to
convey right something that's entirely
different because if I start thinking
you know I'm not going to try and make
things better right I'd like instead to
harm you that's that's qualitatively
different oh it's almost like you know
what it is it could be I don't know what
you think about this but
is uh in which direction
your motivation is pointing so if in the
response to the feeling of jealousy
your sort of
um the motivation says okay I understand
this feeling I want to do less of it
I think there's there must be a
threshold to which you actually want to
do more like it becomes a vicious
downward cycle so that's what Envy
becomes like the first feeling this idea
that I'm gonna kill the farmer
it turns into like more and more and
more and you can't sleep and you're
visualizing the farm and it becomes the
devil and like you have this very you
know it's it's a it's basically a thing
that builds into the negative Direction
versus returns to the stable Center yeah
now a person is cultivating evil yeah
right they're saying hey there can be
seeds of Evil in all of us let me take
that seed out dust it off plant it
nurture it right and then grow that seed
of evil which will affect all other
parts of the person's life right they
they won't behave the same towards
others in their in their life they'll
they'll they'll become different as they
nurture fantasies of evil as they begin
to create with side within inside of
themselves the the motivation and the
will right to enact the evil right the
Hitler analogy would say look you take
someone who had a bad childhood right
who who like was not loved who who was
taught and told that he was less than
okay like that we know that happens I
mean that's why child abuse is so evil
right it's telling children the the
worst possible wrong lessons right
they're not good enough they'll always
be hurt you know they can't keep
themselves safe they don't deserve
safety right so then you take someone
who then nurtures that seed of evil
which is a choice and says well I can't
paint well enough and no one appreciates
me and I don't like how I look and I
don't fit in with the people I want to
fit in with and then and on and on and
on and on and on and there's a hatred of
self through that lens of misery of just
being repulsed by the self but that's
unacceptable to the self so oh it has to
be someone else's fault
right it's not my fault whose fault is
it right and then you see on mass the an
action of evil towards groups of people
who who somehow in this person's mind
right are responsible for his misery and
there's the justification of evil and
then all the you know whether it's this
will be better for the economy this will
be good this will be that like that's
all lies built to justify the evil those
are surface level narratives yes and the
Envy is the the deep down mechanism that
enables and that's the endpoint that's
being served what's being served is
destruction right which is why it always
brings more destruction right I mean how
many times do do
Wars that were started for purposes that
we would look and say like those were
evil purposes like how many times
does good come of that even we look at
the modern world what comes of it is
more evil is more destruction and
Hitler's outward destruction eventually
came Inward and you know you see
pictures of what Berlin looked like
after the second world war right it
wasn't just destruction perpetrated
outward as awful as that is it's it's
it's catchy right like people used to
worry if you you know before the during
the time of the Manhattan Project right
if you start this Chain Reaction you
know will you blow the whole world up
right or will it stop within this bomb
or not and we see okay the chain
reaction of evil hasn't yet blown the
whole world up but look at the look at
how the catastrophe spreads and you
think 50 to 60 million people dead in
the second world war which truly was a
World War what destruction was spread
around the globe and this is something
that can't be stopped once the Chain
Reaction starts like if Hitler was
successful like it would just keep going
if he had been I think if it's personal
psychological level I mean right because
we think from the perspective of
Destruction success would have needed
led to the need to conquer more then
there's factions and infighting and then
eventually you get the same mass
destruction right and and never does the
inaction of evil satisfy what the person
is initially seeking like people want to
feel better about themselves right we
like winicot who was uh a British uh
pediatrician who who wrote about
children and adults from a very deep
perspectives he wrote about the idea of
good enough right and then you can sort
of extrapolate that like we all want to
feel good enough like not just limp over
the line good enough but I want to feel
good enough that I'm a decent person in
the world and like what I do matters and
you know I can I can have an impact on
people and you know people can like me
and care about me it's there's a
Simplicity there that people want that
when people don't have and there's
certain other factors maybe they're
temperamental factors or historical
factors can lead to trying to soothe the
that deficit right through envy and and
I think it starts with with it starts
with that and it often starts in
childhood not always but it often starts
in childhood when when the the child's
brain and psychology are so vulnerable
and you know you see Salient child abuse
if you know if you look at what was
Hitler's background and what was
Stalin's background and I mean you could
you could look at almost anyone who's
perpetrated evil or they're serial
killers or whatever it may be the the
majority not everyone but the majority
had these lessons in childhood that said
you're not good enough you can't keep
yourself safe no one cares about you and
and in a subset of people that's going
to generate envy and that you know that
that seed of evil then gets planted and
nurtured
as a fighter jet Brewers above us the
sound of a fighter Jetta boss it's been
good by an orchestra if you get you
quickly forget the comfort of being in a
peaceful place that's one thing I saw in
Ukraine
is um
hey you quickly get comfortable here the
whole trip back
I was thinking it's so damn good to be
in America it's a whole just a whole
like it's like a three day trip back
it's so good to be American
we might take that for granted
it's a population but I do agree
so the destruction never alleviates the
envy
are all humans capable of envy
I believe the answer is yes if you think
do we all have the possibility of evil
in us I think the answer to that is yes
but we have
free will we have choice we we can
choose what we do with that which is why
just because someone is a sociopath you
know for example is it doesn't mean that
they're not responsible I mean our you
know our medical legal jurisprudence
right has
um has absolutely borne that out that
legally medically we think okay if we're
responsible presuming we're healthy
we're not unhealthy in other ways it
eliminates our ability to to be
circumspect but that we're responsible
for what we do and don't nurture inside
of us I mean there are plenty of things
we could decide to nurture anger and
hatred about you know I can think of
slights difficulties whether it's
something someone else has done to me or
I could blame fate or I could be mad at
God or the world we can all make those
choices and we're responsible for them
or if we're recognizing things in us
they're like oh I you know I too have
that in me but I don't want to nurture
that I don't want to Foster that or do I
choose to nurture and Foster that and I
think ultimately in our subject of
Hitler as as evil if Hitler had kept
winning and winning right I think
ultimately he would have been the only
person on Earth
right and I really do believe that
ultimately everyone everything else
would be killed because it's such
destruction right destroy everything
right and probably when that didn't work
then there's the destruction of the self
right because
nothing
soothes
envy that is stoked by the sort of
flames of evil and what you see is more
and more anger and more and more
frustration which is why I really do
believe someone like that who who
nurtured evil in themselves that way
ultimately would would destroy they'd be
like him and one other person then he'd
kill the other person I think that's
really powerfully said but even just to
return to the jealousy versus Envy I
still think that it's the same Flame
and envy is just the bigger version of
it so I I think
I just in my own personal life
I've felt jealousy towards others like
you said like oh this person
has a I don't know a cooler thing drink
it whatever trinket I cared about and
usually it's when somebody's really
close to the the trinket You're Building
uh and I I early on like in my teens
I realized that
just just empirically speaking that
jealousy over a period of a week just
doesn't feel good
and it's not productive it doesn't help
me build a better trinket
um or it does if I turn it not into
jealousy
towards another person but into a love
for building a better trinket it's like
oh cool almost you know what like
proactively speaking uh and later in
life like people like Joe Rogan actually
have been really uh powerful in this for
me just as a fan of his
to celebrate other people so it's almost
as opposed to ignoring that other person
with a cool trinket it's like
celebrating their awesomeness in my mind
yeah like just saying how awesome the
humans are able to do that and actually
just how awesome is that exact person
and being able to do that yeah and that
somehow made me more capable to build my
own trinket better yes and it feels good
also like it makes me feel happy and now
you're not jealous anymore you're not
jealous anymore right so that's why I
think jealousy is different right
because he's saying there's a week of
jealousy like I don't like this right I
don't like but if you take that in a way
that says wait a second actually this is
awesome this is fabulous and this person
did this that person's awesome right
then
then what you're not raining on anyone's
parade right and in not doing that even
inside your own mind you you gain a
greater cognizance of your own
capability right well if he if he can do
that or she can do that why can't I too
like I want to build I want to make the
better trinket too right yeah now you're
thinking creatively nowhere in there
nowhere in there was the emergence of
evil I just disagree with that I think
there was a choice made where I I looked
at my if my life was darker more
difficult I think it has nothing to do
with the actual little flame of jealousy
I felt I think he has to do a lot more
with the other context if if I
if if my life were more difficult there
was more abuse there was more challenges
I think that decision I could have made
that decision a different direction yes
maybe I don't know
um yeah you you've written brilliantly
about trauma if there's a bit more
trauma as the background noise of my
decision making I'll be more likely to
uh not be able to uh pull away from the
gravitational field of that jealous
Scene It would build and build and build
a build so I think I it's not to
disagree with the brilliant a person but
like I feel like that flame that flame
has the capacity to engulf the whole
world I guess the initial flame of
jealousy the little bit like especially
the Younger You Are
it's a it's almost like a habit you get
to build in either direction because
I've early on built a habit of saying
I'm going to uh channel that jealousy uh
into productivity and into celebrating
other people in that jealousy disappears
that was like a little Discovery for me
I discovered that I get it that doesn't
come nobody tells that to you you kind
of discover that little thing I could
have easily not discovered it I could
have easily discovered
that it kind of feels good to to like
mess with that other person to like uh
think uh shitty thoughts think negative
thoughts do negative things to the other
person because that could also I I just
think the capacity in that initial
feeling is there and I think it's the
decision we make because like otherwise
I think it dissolves responsibility
like well surely I'm not Hitler
therefore this jealousy is normal no I
just feel like every jealous has the
capacity to turn into maybe not Hitler
but a toxicity that destroys in a small
way in your own little private life but
it could destroy I agree that
jealousy brings us
can bring us dangerously close to Envy I
mean maybe maybe let's see if if
um a heuristic we could agree on right
let's see so let's say okay if we look
at the terrain of the mind is geography
right so if I'm feeling happy satisfied
probably like I'm pretty far from from
Envy land right right but but if I'm
feeling jealousy now I'm I'm I'm coming
kind of closer to that border right and
I still I think there's it's a big thing
to go over the border right that the
Border isn't a gray area right there's a
border to go over and I think that you
you I agree completely once certainly
about trauma that the more trauma there
is because then the more
misunderstandings there are about self
and feelings that I'm not good enough
and then that can be anger about why and
who might be oppressing me and you know
I hate myself and everyone else who
seems to be better like so the trauma
can drive us in these negative
directions but we're still crossing over
something right so so if you have the
trinket and I think that's awesome I
want that I want to work harder you know
what I could do though is I could sneak
in tonight when no one's around and I
could move something around no no way I
don't want to do that right but it's
like I came over the Border a little bit
and I thought maybe maybe that's a
better way but then I came back right
and I'm and you're we're responsible for
that right because it is a choice to say
I don't want to work hard I'm already
working how how hard I don't want to
make my trinket better I want to think
mine's the best one I could destroy
yours right and you know we're letting
our mind go over that border and do we
say right run that forward right let's
run that forward and put people around
us who feel the same way and start doing
it so we think less of ourselves and we
debase ourselves do we run headlong in
or do we come over that boundary and
that's maybe the capacity for evil in us
that we come over that boundary all of
us right at times but do we come over it
and then said no that that's not my
choice that's not my self-definition I'm
coming back but I'm trying to justify
maybe there are certain other
sociological forces that help us cross
the border too so in Nazi Germany we've
been talking about Hitler but then
there's also the the German people and
so maybe when there's a bit of a mass
hysteria so all these effects of like uh
combination of propaganda with the small
jealousies and resentments of the people
that don't cross the border uh uh
together they can with with great
charismatic leaders that sort of uh
really fuel that fire that we feel when
we're part of the crowd so maybe those
individual kind of psychological
barriers we have to take that leap from
jealousy to Envy those can be made
easier the the leap can be catalyzed
through this mess 100 100 I think that
to me is a massive point we're talking
about layers of emergence right so if
there's individual Consciousness then
there's culture right and you know we're
products of the soup we swim in so to
speak people would say that when I was
growing up right we're products of the
soup we swim in so if the soup that
we're swimming in is the soup of hatred
yeah right then it's going to Foster all
of those things so then you think about
just in a painting with a very broad
brush the culture created in Germany
prior to the second world war and like
what was the impact of the reparations
after the first world war right of the
the punishing reparations impoverishment
and you know basically humiliation right
that people were feeling okay like
that's there were a whole bunch of
decisions that impacted that cultural
perspective right then there must have
been aspects just like I see in many
ways parallels in in America now of what
are our standards for what we're
communicating to others right how is the
media deciding like what's real and
what's not real what's true what's not
true what's hatred that that is only
going to do evil versus what's hatred
that's okay because I might sell
something by by putting it out there I
mean that was we know that was going on
in Germany during the rise of the Nazis
and and I think there's a parallel to
you know do we value truth do can we
stand together and say no matter how
much I might disagree with you
politically right we can still
understand like that there's there's
right and there's wrong right there's
truth and there's lies right so so I
think those are just two examples of
determinants of culture and then the
culture is a determinant of you know is
someone like Hitler marginalizes like
that's a that's a crazy evil person oh
my goodness like whoa right or is that
someone who gains a greater following
and more adherence and then there starts
to be a momentum because why because
what did demagogues do I think they they
have a giant lasso and they harness the
Envy of of thousands upon thousands upon
thousands of people that's right you
feel worse about yourself too doesn't
matter what the reasons are maybe it's
your childhood maybe it's not maybe it's
job failings maybe it's professional
maybe it's personal doesn't matter like
you have nv2 let's put it together and
do some destruction because that'll make
us feel better which is a lie
so we've talked about Envy where does
from the leader perspective uh things
like narcissism or sociopathy
psychopathy come into play
what can you make of
the world we live in maybe the leaders
that run the world from the perspective
from the lens of narcissism so I am
struck 20 years of doing
what I do now I've been a psychiatrist
for 20 years and I've practiced in so
many different settings and I consult in
different settings I've been fortunate
to have a very wide purview of like
what's going on in people and in the
world around us
and I am struck with amazement that of
all the things I see that I say abnormal
let's say from the mental health
perspective this could be depression
panic attacks uh hearing voices
addiction but there's so many things
that cover everything
that narcissism is not
frequent compared to a lot of other
things so it's it's it's small in terms
of their narcissistic diagnosis right
it's it's much less than many other
things but it causes the Lion's Share I
don't just mean the most compared to
anything else but but I think more than
50 the majority of
bad things evil things destructive
things that I that I see in the world
around us I think narcissists are wildly
destructive because they are driven
completely they are lodged completely in
the lane of Envy
can you um try to sneak up and we don't
want to be lost in definitions but can
you try to sneak up to a definition
non-clinical definition of narcissism
that we're talking about so narcissism
is a deep
pervasive and unquestioned sense of
inadequacy
in the self that comes along with anger
and fear and vulnerability
fear of Destruction fear of annihilation
that is compensated for by
aggression by is it by the the mechanics
of Envy by trying to make the self uh
seem better at the expense of others by
taking from others uh by being
completely Cavalier to the thoughts and
feelings of others that narcissism is
not arrogance now narcissism is the
opposite of arrogance there is such a
deep sense of inadequacy and
incompetence in the self that the
defensive structure around that becomes
dominated by rocket fueled Envy
so the Machinery of narcissism is Envy
but uh what do you make of the kind of
more popularly discussed kind of symptom
of narcissism which is a seeming
not caring about other people
sort of a very inward facing focus in
terms of the calculation you make when
making decisions about the world
narcissistic people definitely care
about other people right it's the people
who are schizoid right and say that
don't don't necessarily register other
people right but narcissism people care
about other people but it's entirely
vis-a-vis the self right if I'm schizoid
I don't really notice or care much who
you are right but if I'm narcissistic I
absolutely care because I'm watching
every last detail of you what might you
have that's better than me yeah right
it's it's an it's an incredibly intense
focus upon individuals and demographics
of people but the priority the the the
goal is entirely about the self which is
why it can become easy to say I don't
care if a million people die right
that's how different is that from going
out and destroying one person or a
million people right it's it's in the
same category of those people only there
exist is only meaningful in how it
relates to me
but it's still
meaningful it just seems like a very
difficult uh leap to take that I don't
care that a million people die
that
seems to be even with Envy
that seems to be a big
like feeling and thought to have if you
at all care about them
are other people I guess
tools for alleviation of your sense of
inadequacy right I mean I don't even
care about in that like being caring at
all I mean caring about in that noticing
that the person exists right I mean
someone who wants money and and notices
that there's a hundred dollar bill out
cares about that I mean they don't care
about the the 100 Bill and that doesn't
mean anything to them just have thoughts
and feelings but but it's going to
attract attention they care about it
because it's something that they want
right the same way people will care
about others but only from the
perspective of do you have things that I
want or can I feel better about myself
by taking something from you by making
things worse for you people often talk
about narcissism as like the opposite of
empathy
uh-huh but sort of empathy again depends
how you define it but it's a
is a is a careful consideration
of the mental space of another person of
how the other person sees the world
and and so you're kind of saying that
narcissism narcissistic people would be
also be very good at that in in order to
understand
how maybe the other person can be
manipulated or something to alleviate
your sense of inadequacy right so
there's a difference between the
mechanics of empathy so let's say again
we can Define things different ways
let's say empathic Attunement is the
ability to be attuned and to think okay
what's going on in you what might you be
thinking what might you be feeling some
people have a lot of empathic Attunement
but that's a that's we could look at
that as mechanistic right it doesn't it
doesn't equate to care right an empathic
Attunement
can come along with empathy or not
right so so yes people who are
narcissistic they're they're they can
mentalize well so you mentalize meaning
the ability to to understand or to
consider thoughts feelings motivations
and other people right so so people who
are narcissistic can have empathic
Attunement or mentalization depending
upon how we want to describe those
things but that has nothing to do with
care with actual empathy or kindness or
or consideration so in that sense
empathy usually popularly used means
that you care like your happiness is a
line this is uh I need to read this book
I've read so little science fiction
that's been one of my goals for this
year to catch up on some science fiction
so uh Robert Highland uh from Stranger
in a Strange Land has this quote about
love which is love is that condition
where another person's happiness is is
essential to your own so that's a good
definition I guess of empathy where yes
you're very sensitive so mechanistically
very sensitive to the state of another
person's mind
and your goal is to maximize their
happiness it's like essential to your
own happiness so the the happinesses are
aligned and when that's like elevated to
its highest forms you can call that love
romantic love friendship and so on okay
okay so one more thing about the nurses
some people can be sort of benign
narcissists where they want great things
for themselves right but if they have
enough great things they can sort of
tolerate others being happy too and and
these are people who sometimes are
actually quite highly liked right
because they have to have the most money
the most power the most of anything
anything more than anyone else could
challenge but as long as I have that
it's okay that you have some too right
and then that can make you happy and can
make you like me right so so benign
narcissists can be can be well liked
from that perspective but
it's still all about them and that can
change if for example there's a scarcity
of resources now right but but they're
generally they're not people who are
being overtly destructive although that
they're over the border into the you
know into the Envy territory right
malignant narcissists are very different
where they then want to have everything
so they so even if I have a thousand
times more than you do I Still Envy you
what you have because I want to have I
don't think I can feel good enough about
myself unless I have everything
and once I have everything I won't feel
good enough about myself either and I
don't have to have more right it's like
that's malignant narcissism which we we
think of as sociopathy right again we
can Define these words in different ways
but they're very very negative Concepts
you know it's that's that's profound
sociopathy malignant narcissism uh you
know Envy writ large sociopathy is
malignant narcissism that's a convenient
way to think about it
uh no because we can do sort of
sociopathic things that but not be
sociopathic like well you know I tell a
white lie it's it's like sort of
sociopathy on steroids right is is then
you know Envy writ large is malignant
narcissism well just like you're saying
like there's empathic Attunement as you
said so there's the the mechanistic
aspect of empathy and sociopathy and
then there's the big label you get
attached if you're just doing that thing
regularly I guess living your life
through that lens yeah right yeah and uh
is there a nice Spectrum that's like
narcissism sociopathy and psychopathy is
it all the same kind of a nice stroll
through the woods off the cliff or not
really because
words don't have clear definitions like
psychopathy and sociopathy there's no
there's no there's no real definition of
psychopath or psychopathy or does that
mean someone's sociopathic but psychotic
like there's really not a we end up
using those words colloquially right
which is why you know Concepts that we
can Define like you like Envy empathic
Attunement
um narcissism even though there might be
nuances and definitions like we can
Define them in ways that are widely
accepted including within psychology and
Psychiatry so it's nice to just think
about this a broad umbrella of
narcissism and the levels to which it's
benign or malignant and then also
separating into the different mechanisms
like interaction by interaction which
sometimes can be narcissistic but
broadly speaking do you do everything
through the lens of malignant narcissism
that makes you a right a sociopath or a
malignant narcissist yes and the thing I
would I would add to that is the thought
about culture right it's like how does
the the cultures were in whether it's
the culture of a household right the
culture of a community the culture of a
Nation or the world right how does that
impact what unfolds in that person and
then how does what unfolds in that
person impact that culture well that's
the the question is what unfolds in that
person
yeah how does culture affect it but how
does your own psychological development
unfold that because narcissism in
leaders is the most impactful thing
right who are the most impactful
individuals what is the most impact of
individual psychology we have it's
usually leaders of countries or leaders
of major organizations and so on and one
of the things you mentioned with benign
narcissism it's that seems to be aligned
with success right if you care about
your own success
that that's going to be you're more
likely to be have narcissistic
Tendencies I suppose
um and so my question is when you
follow that threat of narcissism to
become the leader of a country
now you have a lot of new interesting
psychological complexities to deal with
like power that'll cliche that power
corrupts
does that is it possible for power to
corrupt the human mind to where it
pushes you farther and farther
into a malignant narcissism into this
destructive Envy what are your thoughts
on power like the effect of power in the
human mind yeah
power is
um
let's say an accentuator right an
intensifier right so so I think it is
true that there are people who can be
sort of in a gray area where there are
malignant narcissistic Tendencies and
and behaviors but there are also ways in
which that person can think outside of
themselves and think in a broader way
and and think sort of kindly about
others and and they're they're sort of
trying to navigate whether they're aware
or not that they're trying to navigate
between one and the other and then the
Allure of power is well just look just
exercise that power and you'll feel
better right you're gonna it'll show you
right that you're good enough look at
the power you have and whatever may be
going on in the person's mind that then
power yes can corrupt yes I think that's
why we we have to have checks and
balances right because we don't you know
we we are all inscrutable to ourselves
let alone to others so so we must have
checks and balances and we should always
have them on ourselves as well as on
others we should we should want that for
the health of ourselves in the world
around us
um so I think all of that is true but
there are also people who don't
necessarily become I'm corrupted by
power right that there can be an
understanding and a grounding uh that
they're a steward of power right uh you
know a Shepherd you know I mean the ways
people describe utilizing power and
utilizing it a benign what it in a
benign way that then
Fosters the healthy aspects of self
right so like gratitude and humility
right if I mean if we if we could add a
healthy dose of gratitude and humility
to everyone or to our society there
would be a sea change right but how do
you how do you feel gratitude how do you
feel humility those things are
incompatible with narcissism Envy right
with really the bad pull of things that
we're talking about and part of the
reason I you know I'm so focused in my
work and really what runs through all of
my thoughts about life is that the
impact of trauma right because trauma
you know creates these false lessons and
it walls us off from truth and and you
know it starts to point towards the the
unhealthy ways of
um of trying to feel better about
ourselves but we have the health in US
two we have those Seeds of Health too
that can grow into being a steward of
power and sharing power being
considerate and kind and we see a lot of
that in the world too right it's not all
just the evil we you know we see plenty
of people who do good and who are
generous of spirit and you know we have
both in us and it is I think you're
talking about our culture and what the
seeds that we sow and and the climate
that we set including putting Governors
and boundaries around like how do we how
do we rein in or say that the more
aggressive the more envious or
destructive is unacceptable right how do
we Foster the the part that's kind and
considerate and reflective and and slow
to judge of like hey let's learn a
little bit more like how do we Foster
that and I think a lot of that comes
back to early childhood education I mean
I think we don't do nearly enough to
protect children and and as a corollary
to that we don't do nearly enough to
educate children and we said I want to
write a book second book I write is
gonna it's gonna be everything I needed
to know about life I learned as a second
second year postgraduate Psychiatry
resident I was like why you know why
then did I learn so much about
unconscious motivation about the impact
of trauma about how we can be envious
and how we can act out you know even
about how our emotions Trump logic in us
like what why why don't we teach these
things when we're young enough to
understand like why is that other kid
bullying me right or why just because
I'm a little bit bigger do I want to go
thump that other kid on the head like
what what what's going on that we don't
we don't do those things you know we
just we're tripping ahead of ourselves
and we don't stop and think
how are we using our resources how are
we how are we shepherding forward the
Next Generation which by the way is a
generation that's going to determine our
Fates too right as we get older but we
don't you know do that I often think of
like in the Olympics you know you see
like the the great sprinters right and
they've got to come out of the blocks
perfectly right because if they come out
of the box a little bit too fast they're
going to fall over right they're going
to just fall forward and and I I often
just see that in my head about us as you
know as humans and as a culture that
we're rushing so far forward we don't
stop and say wait let's let's keep the
basics here the basic techniques of like
how are we navigating forward in in Life
or do we just throw all those away
because I can get some benefit by
saying that you're bad even though
what's being leveled against you is
wrong right like what why why do do I
take that or do I say no that there's
something more important here that we
want to Shepherd forward in ourselves as
a culture and I think preventing
childhood trauma and changing the ways
that we educate children and adults
would could again make a sea change and
maybe set us on a course towards even
towards a greater likelihood of survival
as a species yeah so talking to like uh
people in in elementary school
about human nature
and teaching them was so uh how people
can be resentful and envious and how how
to deal with your emotions uh how to uh
yeah so these basic interaction things
about human relationships about
friendships about betrayal about love
about all those things like it just it's
actually strange that we don't we kind
of hope the parents talk about that kind
of stuff right but then the parents
often
uh you know need therapy themselves but
parents just didn't learn it yeah I mean
I'm not joking that I was I was mad you
know second year after medical school
like how is it like I think even things
in my own life and you know how I you
know like how much shame I felt after my
brother's suicide like I was already an
adult right as a young adult but I felt
so much shame I didn't like I had no
understanding that that oh look it's
it's a it's a reflex to trauma right to
feel guilt and shame and that of course
I was feeling that it didn't mean it was
true because I felt it but I mapped the
fact that I felt ashamed to the fact
that I should have felt guilty and
ashamed and I like led to some very
negative things in my life and I had to
sort of pull myself back from and
recover from and like I didn't know that
right I didn't know the automaticity of
the reflex and how pervasive it can be
and how it can put blinders on us and I
mean it's just one example but you know
it's example of something big that
happens to people that we don't learn
learn about and I find myself sometimes
having conversations with a person
because I still do a lot of clinical
care of having conversations with a
person after a tragedy and I'm saying I
can't believe right again I'm saying the
things that this person didn't learn in
elementary school because like none of
us did right and then look at the misery
and the suffering and then I think this
is one person among how many millions
Among Us who you know who try and go
about their way without knowing things
that are easily knowable because they
don't even know that they're knowable
because we don't teach them to ourselves
so how to deal with trauma that trauma
happens first of all uh that suffering
can happen and small trauma and big
trauma all that can happen and there's
natural ways to deal with it so
um in the case of traumas you write
about
and we can also just talk about some
more of the details of that but it's
it's good to uh bring it to the surface
to talk about it to not be ashamed to
hide it inside to be some kind of secret
uh that it's actually
uh I mean there's a lot of positive
things to say here at least from my
perspective one is it's discussing
trauma and dealing with trauma together
with other human beings by talking about
it is a path to deep friendship and
intimacy with those people
um there's a dark aspect to trauma to
war that
communicating it or sharing it
bonds you yes so like the other side of
trauma is like love is uh you need that
hardship not you don't need it but
hardship and Trauma can often be a
catalyst for a deep human connection if
you bring it to the surface as opposed
to kind of hide it on the inside I mean
if we can just Linger on it because
you've been through a few
uh very traumatic events in your life
when you were 25 years old as you
mentioned your brother committed suicide
what did that event teach you about life
about death
and about the human mind
what certainly brought me face to face
with the truths of life and death
because I had not had
a major trauma before then so there
wasn't a major trauma sort of in my
developmental years that what can carry
forward is a sort of omnipotence defense
right I mean the thought is that when
we're toddlers we all have like an
omnipotence defense which is like I can
just try and get up and run and move and
if I run into something I'll get up and
do it again right that we you know we
kind of have to and it's part of the
protection of the parent Etc but we we
think we can get out there in the world
and do things and we just do and if we
don't have major traumas we can sort of
carry through the oh like bad things
aren't going to happen to me you know
like they I know that they're there and
I know they happen to people but they
don't happen to me right and sometimes
what will happen is being confronted
with such a tragedy wipes that away very
very quickly and then the person feels
extremely exposed like oh I I thought
that like I was going to be okay and now
I know that I'm not and then and that
can start to lead to what does that mean
and now is this all coming for me now
you know is is did I get so lucky for 25
years nothing bad happened on nothing
but bad things are going to be happening
am I cursed is my family cursed right
and and I think that leads to say what
the learning about the human mind
in retrospect I I think I understood at
the time to some degree but not like I
do now I can put words to it now right
enough I'm like how
incredibly important powerful uh
powerfully important negative emotion is
right that how a sense of guilt and
shame and vulnerability can can just
pervade our entire life perspective so
all of a sudden we're swimming in a very
different soup and it's a frightening
soup and it's a toxic soup and I'm most
struck by that and and that goes along
with the idea that look we're not taught
that that emotion always beats logic you
know like I think the idea of Descartes
any other idea that we're rational
creatures you know the kind of comes
down to us through Western thought is
like completely not true like we're
rational creatures only if there is an
emotion grabbing for our attention right
like you know we're attending to one
another we're being very logical right
what we're doing now if we heard a
frightening noise right outside the door
like we'd be entirely different right
the emotion would Trump everything is
they stop paying attention to this right
now safety is at stake and we we we
think differently feel differently
behave differently right and this is
what happens to us not just in
situations where something drags us from
Yanks from one emotional state to
another but it can be very very
pervasive so my sense of anger
frustration
inadequacy and then soothing and
unhealthy ways you know soothing by
drinking too much and then kind of
hating myself in the first place and and
hitting the world around me and then you
know starting to think well who cares
you know what happens like you know
there's some very dark thoughts and and
choices that came from a changed
perspective of Self in the world
so what do you do in that
um because of trauma again small or
large
you find yourself
swimming or drowning in a soup of
negative emotion what do you do
what do you do with that emotion I mean
we don't have to even talk about trauma
is I think the interesting thing is
you know
um any one of us throughout the day can
find ourselves
uh taking a bit of a dip in the pool of
negative emotion what do we do with that
the first thing is to separate how we
feel from what's true
because we don't do a good job of that
as humans if I feel
bad about myself it's very easy to then
I conclude like I'm bad right if I feel
ashamed of myself I conclude I'm a
terrible person who's shameful right
this is that you know there's an old
psychodynamic concept of what what these
call an observing ego still gets called
that it's not ego in the sense of
arrogance right it's the ability to step
outside and to to see ourselves right so
that's what lets us keep the difference
between our feelings right and what we
know to be true like we could be very
angry at someone and so I think that
person is terrible I think the person's
stupid I think that right now because
like something negative just passed
between us this inside of me it's just
because of how I feel like when I when I
can separate that how do I actually
think about that person right and you
know we get driven so so frequently by
how we feel because how we think
therefore what we believe right just
kind of comes on its heels as if the
feeling is dragging it along and I've
been struck by that it's one of the
things that has struck me so
the most right among the very most in 20
years of of working as a psychiatrist is
how we are led by our our feelings our
emotions as if they are truth and then
they create truth because we Embrace
what they're telling us as true
and that is I think incredibly I think
it's how people learn Prejudice I think
it's how people learn self-hatred I
think it's how we learn so many
destructive behaviors and then the the
blinders on us come in more and more and
more and more so separate you know we're
driven by what we feel unless we
understand that what we feel is
different from what we know to be true
or what we can decide on one way or
another and that requires
realizing and catching the emotions
themselves realizing that it's an
emotion a feeling comes into your mind
overtakes you a feeling of anger
dislike hatred all of that it just comes
in it's like why did that person just
cut me off in traffic or something like
that that that feeling so what you just
kind of take it as a feeling and
realize it's a feeling that doesn't
represent some deep reality about the
world that's fundamental or you that you
just kind of watch it and
let it pass
which is the natural way of things yeah
we decide if it means anything you know
if I'm mad right someone cut me off and
you know I feel hatred and I want to
destroy them right to stop and thinking
look I I've got that in me I I can you
know the stress is running too high in
my life like is it really good should I
be should I be on this road 10 minutes
behind schedule like is it what am I
really doing so we can learn but but yes
it's an observation skill right and it's
an observation skill that we can develop
you know I often think about you know
there's something called the tapestry
Theory which I think initially was a
theodicy of explaining I believe this is
true I'm not sure of this but the idea
was that oh we don't see God's plan
because we're we're up too close to it
right like as if there was a beautiful
Tapestry on the wall and we're standing
right up it we're only going to see one
part of it we need to stand back from it
and and you know I remember learning
that religion studies class being really
fascinated with that at the time and and
I think that there are a lot of things
things we do that about right and and in
in training ourselves to have an
observing ego what we're saying is hey
look the just the the busyness of life
or my own impulses or the pull of
emotions are trying to pull me up right
close to whatever tapestry there is
there and I want to sort of resist that
I mean I mean I'm better off if I really
stay further behind it and then I make a
choice if I want to come close to it if
there's some really positive emotion or
it's friendship or it's love or it's
nurturing whatever you know what let me
come right up to this right but I want
to choose when I'm doing that I don't
want some Drive I didn't decide to like
take me by the back of the head and and
put me up against that tapestry so the
interesting exercise
uh for me and I think for a lot of
people in modern civilization is the the
internet with social media that it it's
almost like going to the gym or
something like that at least that's the
way I see it because there's a bunch of
forces
on uh social media that are trying to
make you feel things
most of it is kind of in the negative
space of feelings
because
um there is actually a strong gravity
pull to negative feelings for some
reason and so the uh and the Brain
notices them more I don't know what that
pull is but it's there and you get to
observe it on social media like if you
actually just scroll through social
media
you feel the gravitational pull of
negative emotions and I I just see as a
kind of exercise of like
you feel the pull just like when you go
to the gym there's a resistance and I
practice like stopping a stepping away
to look at the tapestry right it's and
there's different mechanisms I think all
of us have to learn uh for me there's a
kind of uh you mentioned uh gratitude
and humility so
like if somebody uh if it's me
personally I've recently gotten attacked
a few places here and there uh uh you
know if they're saying that they're much
smarter than me I practice kind of
humility like you mentioned and I kind
of imagine that they are smarter than me
those things like help me to kind of
like pull away like and then maybe they
have a lesson to teach me like I don't
take their sort of negative comments to
Heart right but I imagine the human
being and like that they they might have
a lesson to teach me and in general when
it's more amorphous kind of negative
feeling I'll think the other thing is
the Gratitude just like uh different
versions almost
mimifiable versions of like oh this is
pretty cool like we got a thing going
here there's like human civilization
like bickering and having a little fun
like lunch food fight and it's kind of
cool like we get to interact in this way
and
um there's a bit of humor there's a
Thanksgiving dinner like if you like
Thanksgiving dinner if you're arguing
about Paul it can feel like really
intense like I can't believe you said
this but if you zoom out it's like
family this is like this is amazing so
that kind of feeling uh really helps and
but it's like it really is like going to
the gym it's like building up a muscle
to be able to um
pull away from those emotions like
I don't think I get to practice that
kind of emotion regular day-to-day life
because like you can't it's hard to get
those reps on social media you could
really get the Reps in it's kind of cool
like that's the way I I see social media
is a chance to sort of practice that
stoicism of like of gratitude of
humility of loving other people in the
face of this negative emotion all that
yes and you know there's there's a
certain kind of psychotherapy that that
talks a lot about this idea that like oh
everything is as it should be right
which doesn't mean from some moral or
Justice point it's just that often if
you look at things
one thing leads to another to another to
another in a way that's actually very
very predictable even though we might be
surprised about it right and so an
example so I would say that gratitude
often does come along with a healthy
Pride right so so you you could say in
the example you gave I'm being assailed
on social media okay
so you can say well you know there was a
time I sat out I I set forth to impact
people right to to be able to reach
people and to impact them right and look
I feel a sense of both gratitude and
pride that I've done that right because
because you did it because of your your
effort right your work your intelligence
your thoughts like you're responsible
for it right but also
you feel gratitude because any one of us
who's here and has any opportunity has
reason to feel immense gratitude right
so then you can say okay what's actually
going on here is something successful I
set out to do something and and I'm
doing it right
and what it brings with it absolutely
includes being assailed there's no
surprise there right that that because
of because you know people who have
anything good serve as lightning rods
for Envy so then yes there will be
people who want to make up lies or
whatever they want to do because you
become a lightning rod for Envy by
having succeeded at the thing you set
out to do about which you can feel a
healthy pride and gratitude right and
then I think that kind of puts it in its
place I mean you're still going to make
decisions about it but it makes sense
then like you you have a mechanism of
understanding it that not only makes
sense to you but reflects the truth of
what's what you actually have done and
achieved and what's going on in the
world around you well I wonder if we're
all kind of a little bit unique in this
because for me uh I mean maybe it's
useful to kind of talk through my own
experience of it is um for me I try to
avoid especially in those situations to
feel Pride
because
I'm just looking empirically
I feel way happier if I focus on
humility
if I ever think of like oh yeah you know
when you do something meaningful or you
become more popular you're going to
experience these kinds of I feel the
attacks more and I I it's like me versus
the world that's the feeling that you
start getting and that does not create a
pleasant feeling so to me the pleasant
feeling is like uh stepping away like
kind of laughing at it all right like
with a with a smile and not like in a
negative like laughing at people but
just like laughing at the the theater
like the circus of it like this whole
absurd existence we've got going on and
then just having a humility in like
everybody has a lesson to teach me it
just makes me feel good the pride thing
I do like feeling
when uh in in a positive pool of emotion
so if I'm building a trinket
and I finish it I'm like really happy
with myself like I finished this thing
and I usually actually like to do that
alone
like I don't need an audience for Pride
I like to sit there and just like oh
this is cool I did that you know uh but
I just I find that in social
interactions
um pride is just a danger I guess it's a
dangerous drug for me because it like
it's such a small
it's a small step away from then losing
all the humility and then you start
getting very defensive and that's not
going to that's just it starts you on a
spiral of negative emotion
um but I also I mean with with everybody
you've mentioned this and will probably
sneak up to it in different directions
um I do think there's different brains
that we all have like my brain is
exceptionally self-critical like
non-stop it took of a it's like an
engine that's always there
and um
but at the same time you're I'm able to
zoom out and have gratitude and it just
it's as if there's like two brains and
they're like cohabitating happily
and I can uh the better I get at this
the more I can use the one that's
self-critical when I'm trying to be
productive because naturally I'm super
lazy so I'm trying not to be less lazy
I'll be self-critical right and then uh
when I'm not being lazy why just there's
a special moment I want to enjoy that
moment I'll turn on the Gratitude engine
I feel like generic advice that people
would give if your brain is
self-critical it's not a good thing
like you should probably get rid of that
I don't know about that because it seems
to be working yeah like I I kind of like
it I kind of like this grumpy old man
that's in there that's like
like that thing you did that really
sucked
but I was like and I kind of you know
there's a movie Grumpy Old Men okay I I
like I like that grumpy boy the grumpy
cat is in there and it's nice but yeah I
can have a bad effects on relationships
and on uh maybe uh my well-being maybe
as you get older and all that kind of
stuff so yeah you have to monitor all
this kind of stuff but I don't know I
don't know which one is like because
you've kind of highlighted it's good to
have gratitude and humility but it's
also good to have a little bit of Pride
I wonder what that like a set of
ingredients for healthy what like
healthy life looks like for each of us
whether we have to customize and figure
out what that is
because some of the cake is already
baked is the problem and because of the
trauma like if I was like eight years
old maybe I could be a little more
flexible but at this point like you got
the thing you got and it's hard to like
you can fix a lot with it you could it
may not be easy but there's a lot of
plasticity and a lot of pliability there
across all ages
again people are different and there may
be idiosyncrasies of why one person is
in a different place but but as a
general rule I think the answer is
absolutely yes I mean people have
evolved and I've worked with people
who've really changed themselves and
broadened their conception and
understanding you know they're in their
80s or you know we I think we can do it
at any stage of life and I would make a
case for
for intra-psychic so not between people
necessarily right but inside of oneself
for the feeling of Pride and maybe if we
call it self-esteem right like let's say
we call it self-esteem right or we could
call it healthy Pride we could put
either word to it but if you think about
what we're trying to avoid is say a
sense of inadequacy then it is good to
sort of own what's ours
we can put ourselves a little bit out of
balance
um either in terms of building up
resentments or in terms of decreasing
self-confidence right if we're not
owning everything that's ours right so
so a thought thought I would have about
let's say about some pride or some
self-esteem right is it can work against
vulnerability right which we know can
also in some situations push us towards
jumping the boundary into envy and all
of that so so think about vulnerability
if
you conceive okay people are sailing me
and you just go to a place of gratitude
you know it can it can send a message
that okay I'm just lucky and I hope I
continue to get lucky as opposed to like
that's not true right like there's
there's ability inside of me and
discernment inside of me that tells me I
can have a greater sense of confidence
that I'll navigate what comes my way
right so because the The Pride or the
self-esteem part is owning what we've
contributed to the goodness we've
created right which doesn't in a sense
helps us feel better about ourselves and
it also helps us feel armed against say
the slings and arrows of you know
whatever Outrageous Fortune may come
next I don't know I don't know I don't
know again disagreeing with an expert
here yes I think that's generally good
advice but I I think you mentioned
vulnerability
I think it's like uh I've just been
doing a lot of research on Rocket
engines and Fuel and speaking of fuel I
I just think I get a lot from being
vulnerable because vulnerable leads to
Intimacy in friendships and
relationships I get a lot from being
intimately close with human beings just
on a friendship on a on a like a ideal
level in conversations and so on and so
I would rather err on the side of
vulnerability like to me pride is
destructive I think I already
yeah I I already have a pretty good
engine that says like
life is awesome I don't need help for
that that's fine that one is working
it's the it's I I just feel like the way
to face the world
that's full of uncertainty that could be
full of Cruelty is with
uh humility and gratitude I don't know I
did this pride thing it feels like I I
know that for a lot of people it's
really important to really
um really work on Pride to make sure
they don't uh crumble under the pressure
of like the they don't give in to this
insecurity that destroys them but I just
for me empirically speaking I seem to be
happier facing the world with humility
and just being grateful The Pride I'm
really worried about that like I just it
feels more destructive than anything
see what I think as you're telling me
that in order to be presumptuous but I
make some thoughts or some conclusions
that tell me hey you're in a pretty
healthy place right and the reason I say
that is because I agree completely about
vulnerability I mean think about
humility and gratitude make us
vulnerable right it's like wow I'm
grateful thank you I'm grateful for you
you know we could get shot down or
something you know something bad could
happen and something could make us feel
bad so so yes we we need vulnerability
if we if we try and eliminate
vulnerability we're living miles into
the envy you know land right so you're
describing a healthy vulnerability but
then my brain says that's because on the
other side of this the Seesaw so to
speak has to be a healthy sense of self
whether we call it self-esteem or
healthy pride and then I'll cite what I
think is the evidence for that is you
describe the negative voice right as
like the Grumpy Cat right but
that's a good negative voice to have
right because it's telling you like hey
that wasn't your best like come on do
better or right like you can do better
like this you know this there's a
negative voice in some ways but it
believes in you it's right it's it where
that voice could be it could be a
negative voice that says you didn't do
that well because you suck you don't
deserve anything good right why should
you even be alive right I mean like
that's the negative voice that you know
that can gain so much force if there
isn't a balance of healthy self-esteem
so I think because you're well balanced
you know you you have what you need and
then having more of it seems like oh
that's not so good but they're people
whose negative voice isn't the grumpy
CAD it's it's hateful right and then
that's a person who needs to to bring
that into into greater balance yeah I
think my uh my negative voice is like a
grumpy cat that's like a French
existentialist maybe a little bit of a
nihilist but just kind of is
it doesn't get hateful it's not like a
Hitler cat so it's just a little it's a
little more
um yeah I guess there is kind of like
this line that we've come across a
couple of times between the the benign
and the malignant right but of course
you have to monitor that line I just
I think you have to be careful uh
when you face really difficult
situations of
as you've gone through life more and
more difficulties you you face a lot of
loss and suffering especially later in
life
uh you have to be careful with that
voice
uh that that grumpy cat can get awfully
confident and then if you don't have any
source of uh positive emotions in your
life you can become too heavy of a
burden
yes which I think I think this leads us
to I think is a really important fact
right that there are some people like a
significant subset of people who get
happier as they get older they have more
contentment a stronger sense of self you
might think how could that ever happen
right like we're getting closer to death
we're accumulating insults right like
you know everything hurts a little bit
more and we have less energy and we
accumulate losses and traumas why would
anyone
be be healthier across time if you're
happier across time and and what we see
is it's linked to the good to the things
that we're talking about right it's
linked to say let's say vulnerability
versus Pride like there's a good balance
there right there's a lot of humility
there's a lot of self-esteem the person
is is spending a lot of time standing
back from the tapestry and looking at it
right and and what can come into people
is in sort of a sense of equanimity like
I sort of understand you know I'm being
the best person I can be I'm you know
and that's not always even great and
they're things that I don't feel great
about even while I'm trying to do that
but but look I'm I'm being who I'm
choosing to be right and and that
doesn't have to be in some big way I'm
not saying that means any one specific
thing you know that means the person
who's taking care of their cat and
tending their Garden like that's enough
we we have to have the you know love the
ability to put good things out in the
world right and to put our our ability
to work and be to make things different
out into the world and make things
better and if we're doing that we get
happier across time become because we
come to a sense of peace with ourselves
I'm not supposed to be everything I'm
not supposed to do everything I'm not
supposed to fix everything right I'm
also not supposed to suffer all the time
for the things I haven't gotten right
you know what I guess I'm kind of and it
leads back to winnica right the the
British physician of I'm you know I'm
good enough
and that seems to help people feel feel
happy you know contentment and be
generative and productive into later
life it's like that's what we all should
be wanting but it's even it's kind of an
afterthought though some people are like
that as opposed to wait a second right
like what's going on with them and let's
do all of that
Albert Camus writes in Mythic Sisyphus
quote there's only one real serious
philosophical problem and that is
suicide
deciding whether or not life is worth
living is to answer the fundamental
question in philosophy
all other questions follow from that
so basically to be or not to be
uh do you think there's a
uh truth to that statement this question
of why live at all
um do you think there's truth to that
statement being a really really
important question for us to answer yes
yes and what's the answer
I think the answer is yes
and I think kmu answered it yes too no I
I I love his writing and and
you know I think there was a
a streak of nihilism that I think grew
in his writing over the years and and
the thought is I think that Cameo died
by Suicide I think we're not sure of
that because it was a car accident
um but I've always read that as this
this the primary scholarly opinion and I
think it's interesting that after his
death uh a book called the first man was
published which I don't know if he had
intended to publish I don't remember the
specifics about it but it's about him as
a child right and it's interesting the
first man I mean he was the first man in
his existence right the most you know
the one that felt and experienced
everything and there's sadness and and
distress and all in that book but
there's a beauty of of life and living
and experience and and I think to
compare that beauty like that's life
even if something's difficult and scary
and sad like there's something beautiful
around the corner and he's a kind person
and a new discovery you know more what
was in him as a child and I think that
we can get jaded as we get as you and I
were just talking about a few minutes
ago we can accentuate the negative and
Foster the negative and come to a place
where we're looking for some in-depth
philosophical answer you know some thick
book you know that's going to explain
all that to us instead of the Simplicity
that we've been talking about I think
humility gratitude helps us have just
simple
positive experiences feelings of
contentment feelings of connection with
another person learning Discovery and I
think the answer to kingman's question
is yes and I think it lies in his
writing about when he was a child which
I think he saw is less important than
his later writings and the intellectual
heaviness when I think maybe he had lost
his way a little bit from the things he
understood when he was younger so
another way to talk about it and I'd
love to hear what you think is about
these broad categories
let me be started with Kierkegaard of
existentialism absurdism and nihilism
and I think Camus considered himself an
absurdist not actually an existentialist
it's kind of a middle ground where I
think existentialists
I don't want to characterize it in the
wrong way and there's a lot of different
definitions but I think existential is
ultimately
do think that there is meaning
in sort of
pursuing The Passion of life like
pursuing the mo like in living life
that's where you discover the meaning at
that individual level
of fully embracing life
and I think sort of nihilism
is uh again it's kind of like a spectrum
but now listen basically says
there's no meaning
and it doesn't matter
nothing matters
I don't even know but somehow that lands
you in a place that's totally uninspired
maybe not list would disagree with that
maybe there's a way to live a creative
life in a nihilistic mindset and I think
of absurdism is somewhere in the middle
where
pursuing meaning at all
is not a good idea
so kind of I think existentials say you
should be looking for meaning and it's
to be discovered in your own actions in
your own life in the moment and uh
absurdism says life is absurd nothing
makes sense don't look for the meaning
just live just be I think that's kind of
the the the later kamu kind of
um philosophy I don't know if you can
sort of comment on these kind of nuanced
ideas here if there is no
religious guide to your life
what do you think about this kind of
search for meaning do you see that
there's some wisdom in the
existentialist perspective of
discovering it in your own life in this
passion and this kind of day-to-day
existence in the moments of your life
that bring you Joy that kind of thing
you're bringing different sort of
perspectives and trying to tease apart
like wait what are the differences in
those perspectives right and I think
what it points out is that
okay we tend to conflate things as human
beings right and to take two different
things and try and make them into one
but we also I think on the other end of
the spectrum get very overly
reductionist and I think that when we
get to overly reductionist we lose the
ability to learn from anything or to
generate meaning right I mean think
about Sartre who is you know the thought
of existentialism is so consistent with
him right who on the one hand you know
wrote about you know very clear terms
like this is what it is and this is what
it isn't and here's how you're going to
make your meaning in a very like
academically pro-scribed way but he also
wrote short stories like the wall right
where there's something totally absurd
happens right as part of the story right
so I I think what ends up happening is
people either reduce themselves or get
associated with something that is by
being overly reductionist takes us away
from meaning right the idea that look we
don't know if there is a an overarching
religious meaning or you know what we
call a religious meaning or purpose like
we don't know that right
so okay if we take that as a given that
people who say that they know are having
faith like how Spinoza described Faith
right faith is that you don't know but
you believe anyway right it's not
because you have faith now you know
something right because I think that's a
slippery slope to the persecution of
others right so so if we say okay we
don't know
then
you know we're left either deciding okay
well then the hell with everything you
know like is that movie A Strange Brew
right Bob and Doug McKenzie where like
the the breaks don't work on the car and
one of them says oh why bother steering
right so if we don't know that there's
meaning like why bother stealing let's
just give up the ghost right and I don't
think that's even what the nihilist said
I mean I think the coonan said we should
get rid of everything that we've ever
created except Beethoven's Ninth
Symphony and start over from there but
so even people who are very nihilistic
or associated with that yeah a lot of
them are just not liking what we had
built right so if we accept that a lot
of what we have built as humans inside
of us and outside of us is really
counterproductive and doesn't help us
and that absurd things happen in the
world right and that often the way
social structures and systems build up
you build themselves up is absurd I
think our health care System operates in
a way that's absurd right so if we
accept that there are absurdities that
we don't know if there's truth then what
are we left with but like well let's try
and make meaning right or take it you
got set said um yoso yo Amy
circumstancia right I myself and my
circumstances right which is like look
we're we're we can't control everything
we we live in circumstances around us
but within those circumstances we can
make decisions and Define ourselves and
and I think the Brilliance of that and I
think tying it all together right in a
way that's not trying to be in a sense
it ties it all together by not trying to
answer everything concisely that yes we
can make meaning like we see that if
someone trips in front of me I could
walk around them or I could help them up
I mean no one can tell me that it
doesn't matter what I do I absolutely
reject the idea that oh I could step
over them or on them or I could help
them up and it doesn't matter oh yeah be
the try being the person on the ground
right so we create meaning but we live
in our circumstances and there are
absurdities both within us and outside
of us in our social structures and there
are a lot of things that that pretend to
have meaning that don't then there's the
shades of nihilism But ultimately
there's something going on here that's
doing the best we can in the context of
just not knowing
yeah I tend to see I don't know if it's
genetic I think I tend to think just
observing the internet the number of
memes there are uh
I think many other people are like me I
tend to see the the humor in the
absurdity
and I tend to enjoy it from that kind of
angle I see the kafka-esque nature of
society of different aspects of society
and just kind of notice the magic with a
smile
and just laugh at the circus of it all
because it is magical that the circus
all comes together it's like a little
bit out of sync and then just a guy
playing trombone but like overall it's
pretty good it's pretty good right and
we can look at that and just kind of
Marvel and go yeah right which which I
think is a relation to at least a lot of
what we in the Western World think of as
Eastern right it's like as
non-attachment right because then if
there's something absurd and it's like
not good for me you know right then I
accept that too instead of getting angry
about it and railing about it or seeing
some Cosmic meaning in it right I think
there's also a healthy non-attachment in
what you're saying too so there's uh I
mean you mentioned Eastern thought
there's uh
but also Buddha have kind of uh spoke of
life is suffering uh do you think
there's truth to that that suffering is
a is a fundamental part of life
I think it is a fundamental part of life
I don't think that means that life is
suffering right if we say well life is
suffering then what am I doing that I'm
trying to erase from my mind like the
birth of my children right like things
that were filled with joy right like
life is not entirely suffering but life
brings a lot of suffering and for some
people it brings such disproportionate
suffering and the people don't survive
the suffering and I think when people
are conscientious and empathic that that
really bothers us right the suffering in
our own lives and the fact that others
at times could could seem to be so
overwhelmed by suffering that they don't
even get a chance
to see good and I think that there's I
do think there's truth to that and
there's sadness and distress to that but
to say therefore life is suffering I
think is just completely untrue and you
know it ignores the fact that someone
even made a trombone right let alone
that there's a little bit out of sync
and someone's playing the trombone like
that's cool there's there's a you know
there's elements of the Absurd that you
said are neat and interesting and and if
we start accepting that we can't
understand or control everything then we
can accept and I think really love and
Foster the beauty in our lives
yeah I think uh the word suffering is
doing a little bit too much work because
I think it's probably referring to the
philosophical concept of that uh
yeah this is absurd the absurdity right
that stuff just happens randomly
um evil people succeed good people fail
right there's a seeming random Injustice
on occasion right and occasion there's
Justice in uh yeah all of it that feels
like um and maybe because it often
there's a lot of loss and then there's a
kind of
matching complementary aspect to any
good feeling that all comes crashing
down like every hello right from a
physics perspective ends in a goodbye
like uh
that's a really sad thing like I've I've
uh you know all the amazing people I get
to meet in my life all the amazing
experiences eventually they have to end
and that's part of what makes them
amazing
but why is that sad is it because we're
taught to think that I tell you look at
some point you and I are going to say
goodbye today like I hope we're richer
for it and then we take that goodness
off with us like I I want to celebrate
that because it's it's all part of the
goodness I think we're taught to think
oh that's so bad and it equates to death
and misery and
it's I think it's often not that way I
think there is a sadness to it but I
also don't think that sadness isn't a
negative thing it's a it's a different
way to celebrate a beautiful thing so
there's a melancholic nature to it or
something passing of of it leaving is
that old Louis CK thing that I go back
to over and over uh from from a show
Louis where um
uh he was all heartbroken that he just
broke up you know with the um with
somebody he loved
and he told about that to an old man and
the old man said uh you're a fool that's
the best part I missed that part where
you sort of are lingering in that loss
you're feeling the pain of that loss
because that lasts the longer it's the
most intense it's the most reliable and
it's a kind of celebration of the love
you had like losing the love is still a
celebration of the love
um I think you don't want to over
romanticize that but there's some aspect
of Truth to that like that melancholic
feeling of remembering a beautiful time
that's no longer there
is is a kind of celebration of it and is
a kind of Joyful experience even though
it it's it's very easy to experience it
as a negative emotion I think it's just
like you said I mean it's up to our mind
to determine how that emotions really
felt but it's a tricky one because it's
like heartbreak to experience that is a
positive thing people can reminisce at
funerals right and and laugh because
other people can be very very sad and
perceive that this that this person is
has died and perceived the sadness of it
but in perceiving that and really living
in it then you can have people who want
to remember that person by like telling
a funny story why because each of those
people carries that with them so I I
think what you're saying is is
consistent with healthy function as
human beings because we're going to
encounter sadness and loss like what do
we do with that right and do we do
things that ultimately create some
redemption or even reparation inside of
us and like reparation is a big word in
Psychology right it's how we repair
damage and loss so if we lose someone
and we're sad can we by telling funny
stories about that person remind
ourselves that hey they're still inside
of us whether they're out there look at
me I don't know but I can call that
person of mind inside of us and then we
have something that's that's good and
beautiful that comes of that too
in the introduction to your book on
trauma
Lady Gaga wrote it she wrote the forward
the intro
she said this about you quote I can now
say with certainty that this man saved
my life
he made life worth living this goes to
our discussion about uh the uh the
Mythic Sisyphus kamu question about why
I live
so I think at least to me she's one of
the most brilliant and unique artists
ever so
it's a difficult question but a question
of creativity what role does trauma play
in um
in somebody like that in this artist
that has created some incredible things
uh what positive constructive
a role does trauma serve and what
limiting role does it serve in
preventing that person from flourishing
more trauma can certainly drive us to
creativity right the two even to push
again so to protest against what the
trauma tells us you know trauma tells us
lessons like nothing matters and you
don't matter and nothing will ever be
good and then nothing is beautiful and
and we can push against trauma they know
there is life in me there's something
there's goodness for me to spread in the
world to express and spread so I think
trauma fuels creativity in many many
many ways trauma also shuts down
creativity right of people who are for
it's one example a trauma that escalates
to the point where now the person is
soothing it with alcohol it's one
example and now the impact of the
alcohol shuts down any creativity so so
can people be creative and outward
thinking without trauma I think
sometimes if I remember correctly people
will use in mind you well Kant is an
example of someone I think hadn't
traveled much and didn't have trauma and
like look at what he knew so okay
they're going to be exceptions right but
a lot of our creativity is in some ways
fueled by our suffering although it's
complicated because it comes from
generative places in us right so those
places are there they're not created by
suffering but maybe suffering makes an
incentive or a passion inside of us and
and a person you know Stephanie who you
referred to is just such an incredible
astounding creative force and sure some
of that comes from trauma some of it
comes from you know trauma fueling
degenerative creative places in her but
what I helped her to do she's very
generous with her words but but what I
helped her to do was to see all that she
is and all that the creativity in her is
and all that there is to to create
through love and caring and uh
compassion and and to again see that I
mean a lot of time that's that's what
I'm doing clinically I think it's what's
good psychiatrists or mental health
professionals do is we help people see
the beauty that is there right because
oftentimes we're way too close up to
that tapestry and what brings us close
is often the sad thing so we're up close
in all we see is the negative I mean
it's easy then to get classically
nihilistic but by helping someone take a
step back and to see who they are and
what's in them that's how people get
better and it's how people re-engage in
in life it's such a difficult thing
because if you were to
for studying human beings
it seems like the optimal trajectory
is having some trauma that doesn't
destroy you
that forces you early in life to really
struggle with the intricacies of The
Human Condition
and then later in life as you form and
like you build an expertise around and
mastery
start to do exactly what you said would
you step back and look at the tapestry
so if you if if uh if you don't have the
trauma it seems like just empirically
speaking there's of course just a huge
amount of data and all kinds of
anecdotal evidence but it and I'm I want
to be careful here because maybe I'm
romanticizing
uh hardship
but it does seem that hardship and
childhood
if it doesn't break you can be
constructive it's like like you said
having that trauma one of the ways to
fight it is to say I am worth something
right I am and this is you know
um David Goggins talks about this is
like this is um
I am somebody I I can't be somebody
special and I'm gonna prove it to you
I'm gonna do this I'm gonna do this big
thing it's this engine that drives you
forward yeah comment on that because
like from a like a parent's perspective
you want
a child to have an easy life
right you want them to uh not have
hardship certainly not have trauma
but that's such a difficult dance
because
um in some ways a little bit of hardship
in a gradually increasing amount of
hardship that doesn't break you can
really develop you into a really
interesting complicated
um person and it helps you flourish as a
creative being I don't know what the I
don't know I don't know if there's a
question I'll just keep saying random
things no it makes look I think it makes
good yeah it makes good sense to me I
think you're trying to get at like we
need trauma and like and what and how
are we defining it right because we say
trauma hardship difficulties I mean we
could set aside we could we could set
apart say and differentiate things that
are difficult but that are overcomeable
right yeah versus things that we could
use trauma the word trauma this way if
we if we chose to that are just like
entirely negative like like someone
saying oh
you can't do that and you'll never
succeed because well and then they tell
you something about yourself okay
because you're from here you're this
race religion whatever it is right we
think well you know it could that could
make someone say hey I'm going to show
you I'm going to overcome right but then
they're overcoming something bad right
like it's just like there's nothing good
or helpful about that right if someone's
saying that so the person has to
overcome it that's different than
something that is placed in front of a
person where where the whole conception
of it is something positive that you can
make through effort right so you know I
remember how do I think I was 15 years
old there's some rule like we you could
then go I don't think was picking
raspberries or blueberries right and I
think and my parents wanted me to see
like okay let's go see how that works
here now you got 50 cents at the end of
it right and then you think about that
when you know you want to buy baseball
cards or you you know you think about it
and you you work hard and I could
remember like it was hard and I was
sweating and I was tired and but I
learned from it I mean so the reason I
remember it today so so yes parents
might want their kids to have like a
good life right but not necessarily an
easy life you know and I think that was
done they took me to do that to so I
have a greater sense of responsibility
in a sense of like hard work is
Meaningful and it's important and and I
think that that kind of thing is good
but if we separate that from something
that's just denigrating prejudicial like
I think those things aren't good but
they're unavoidable so it's not
necessarily that always some trauma good
I would look at it more that some trauma
is unavoidable I mean you know it's hard
to how do you go through life and not
have any losses or anything negative or
anything sad and then people are people
there may be people who have not a lot
of that and then there's a sort of
complacency or and they don't do it as
much as they could or feel as good as
they could you know then there's other
people who have a highly attuned
emotional it's the people with very
highly attuned emotional compasses for
which a little bit of trauma becomes so
intrusive so it's so much of it is
person driven but I do want to
distinguish between things that are just
purely bad add that we might overcome or
find some fire in our belly about or
whatever the case may be and things that
maybe boundaries or barriers either
directly purposely placed or not that in
a sense invite us or or inform us of the
possibility of striving and overcoming
finally in tuned emotional compasses
it's so true that there is uh that's a
component of it too it's there's almost
genetic
how sensitive you are to particular
trauma so little things can have a huge
impact or gigantic things uh serious
abuse in in childhood can be by some
people overcome more easily right so
it's not just what's the trauma because
what's the trauma that makes certain
problems you have to match the trauma to
the person and a big part of what you're
matching to is that you know genetically
based characteristic of how finely
attuned is that
empathic Attunement to that Compass so
when you think about if you just return
to Childhood when you think about trauma
and childhood
um what can we say about the impact
of child abuse
on the development of a human being
I think
the impact of it is so
disproportionately
bad and hurtful
compared to things that happen when
we're not children and and I want to be
very careful about how I'm saying that
because people can
through their strength and resilience
and and human interconnectedness can
overcome that I don't mean to say that
anyone who's experienced those things is
can't make it through it or over it
that's that part is not true
but it is true that the impact is so
disproportionate to anything else that
can happen because the brain is
formulating right so so both you know
it's like if we say psychology is like
applied neurobiology right and we look
at both of those as a as as
um different ends right even though
there's a lot of gray in the middle you
know the the neurobiology is changed so
just just one example of a much greater
salience of uh vigilance mechanisms of
of uh mechanisms of self-protection
mechanisms that can make a person feel
more fear and more insecurity and hide
themselves away from the world and not
trust the world and I mean I mean not
trust the world even enough that oh I
you know I'd like to have a better job
and there's and you know another one is
here that I could take but maybe it
could be worse you know they think of
being afraid of that right like there
are all sorts of ways in which in which
the changes to those Pathways impact
someone and and that's just one of you
know we could bring trauma experts
together that could talk about that for
days right like what is the impact upon
the brain biology so that then gets
changed inside the person and from the
perspective of those changes the
psychology on top of it changes like
what do I think about myself do I think
that I'm worthwhile you know even in my
mid-20s after you know uh without
formative traumas in a pretty strong
sense of self and some achievements
there was a there's a big trauma then
with the death of my brother and I start
questioning am I cursed am I worth
anything I mean at 20 something years
old and and doing reasonably well at the
time you know what how does this impact
a child of six seven ten twelve years
old right we're sending such powerful
messages that then change conception of
of self and that negatively changed
conception sits upon the negatively
changed neurobiology and I think if we
really thought hey let's do the best we
can just for humans in general for the
human race our species in general is we
would handle children and and caring for
children so much differently in terms of
protection mechanisms intervention
mechanisms how many times do you see
where where like there's now there's
been some trap some tragedy and the
child gets a little bit of support and
you know they had they had some therapy
you know that was provided by some
insurance carrier you know that they got
once a week for 16 weeks or whatever I
mean we should be wrapping our societal
resources around children but we don't
use our resources well you know I was
just reading it's a little bit of an
aside but about 300 and something
billion dollars a year in cost to the
U.S economy just from schizophrenia and
you think
it cost a fraction what do we actually
put into caring for people who have
schizophrenia so so first there's a
moral imperative but let's say we put
that aside and we only care about the
economy right because there are
mechanisms of thinking that look at it
that way how could we not amend that
right but we are so reckless with our
resources and we're tripping ahead of
ourselves that we don't think oh my
goodness there is no better place on
God's Earth for prevention than here
prevention in terms of human suffering
and also where where do people like that
go I mean more often people like that go
to place of increased suffering
inability to take care of themselves or
to be in in supportive relationships
okay we know there's a higher prevalence
of that but we're also creating the pool
of people through which the Envy the
narcissism the sociopathy the
destruction arises so again if we care
about people we would be so focused on
that if we don't care about other people
and just ourselves or just economic
costs we would still be so focused but
you know we're not and we tend to just
kind of call it good because we don't
see anything disastrous happening at the
moment
um and I think there's a societal
negligence there to the shame really of
all of us
um when child abuse and the impact
neurobiologically and psychologically is
potentially the greatest cause of
suffering directly and indirectly on the
face of the planet
how much does trauma
of that kind and and later in life
affect your ability to love another
human being
saying inside a relationship connect
with another human being
it can impact it a lot and again I want
to say can people overcome and be as
loving to to a partner or a child or
anyone else yes but we're talking across
Society right how are we setting the
odds right we're setting the odds
towards a higher sense of vigilance a
decreased sense of self-confidence an
increased sense of vulnerability right a
decreased Comfort interacting with
others right what we're doing is we're
pushing towards isolation and misery and
depression and resentment I mean those
factors push towards that you know we
know that the research is so strong that
at you know adverse childhood
experiences and these things that happen
the more the worse the more prolonged
the more that person is up against as
they try and navigate life
and uh I suppose one of the elements of
intimacy like what we're talking about
is is vulnerability
and maybe there's a
is there a fear of being vulnerable
of being hurt again
is that ultimately the barrier to
intimacy yeah if you taught a lesson
that says the world is not safe
and you're not good enough for someone
to keep safe and you're not strong
enough to keep yourself safe that's a
final common pathway of of the vast
majority of child abuse right is telling
those lessons to people then how how can
that not
change the lay of the land against
against openness against the ability to
to rationally consider trust and
mutuality and to protect oneself but
also take chances and you know do the
things that we have to do to to create
the greatest happiness in our lives we
set the odds so much against us as
another pathway which I think is uh is
really
interesting because of uh I've seen it
in people is is this kind of ability to
detach yourself
from feeling any emotions
to like protect yourself
it's almost like you're not quite there
it is a word physical isolation of
affect it's a defense mechanism yeah
isolation of affect yeah is that a
common weight another
common way to deal with trauma
well
isolation of affect can cut both ways so
so if there's been a major trauma let's
say someone has seen something terrible
and they're isolated from their affect
and at one time it was thought well
maybe that's good right they're not
hysterical they're not distraught but we
see that is not good right because what
needs to be be held processed you know
we need to get our arms around in some
way shape or form has just been
separated off right so we know that is
not good right but isolation of affect
can also serve us very well when I think
back to being an intern you know a
medical intern in the hospital and you
know you might have to go and
pronounce someone Dead with you know
with hysterical family members and then
you know 10 minutes later five minutes
later might be two minutes later really
you know you have to go to another room
and you've got to maybe do some
procedure that involves you know having
your focus on on a certain thing and
making sure your hand movements are the
right way or talking to a person in a
way that is uh that's very different
than where you just came from that's
very hopeful and so then you have to
isolate the affect of what's going on
around you and it happens not just in
it's just one example but we have to do
it in life so that we can put affect
aside to process later or not feel the
full weight of affect where we know the
meaning like I know the meaning of the
tragedy of the person I just pronounced
dead but I want to separate that for
myself because I'm also aware that it's
not my tragedy so that I can then okay
put that affect aside and go do the next
thing that I have to do so that I think
can cut both ways
right but then you have to like reattach
it
understand that it's good to be close
with emotion even painful emotion
right right like because that's the
Human Experience right it's it's like I
feel like if you if you build up a skill
that you can detach yourself from
emotion
I think that could become its own kind
of yeah it becomes too easy to do it
yeah right and to reinforce that's when
people are suffering too much
over too long a period of time then you
know we're creatures of habit right and
even though our brains are you talking
about our brains are sitting on the
shoulders of the giant of the maybe a
thousand levels of emergence that come
underneath of them our brains are also
also working very simple habit based
ways like if you and I chose a word
right now and said it 500 times we would
know it's just a silly experiment but
we'd both be saying it tonight right
because our brains are also creatures of
habit so if you over and over and over
have to isolate yourself from affect and
you develop those mechanisms well you
develop those mechanisms and they don't
go away any easier than if we said the
word 500 times and decided to forget we
won't forget no matter what we decided
so how do we find our way back
how do we overcome
trauma what are the different Pathways
the first thing the very first thing is
to acknowledge to ourselves and often to
others which might be one other person
who might be in words spoken it might be
written like what the trauma has been
because the the lessons of trauma the
evil lessons of trauma and I'll use
example of my own life the lesson that
told me that I was shameful uh cursed
and hopeless right
it's a very evil lesson right but my
brain will say it over and did say it
over and over and over to me and if that
just sits inside that's how trauma
Fester is that's how trauma hijacks our
thoughts our emotions so being able to
say to ourselves and to another like
this is what's happened right okay this
is what's happened we're built to
massage words and to create meaning
through words right like we don't
massage pictures write images we talk
and massage meaning with words so it so
when I finally went to see a therapist
and I and I could say you know
my brother whatever words I would have
said like he he killed himself and I and
I I can't
accept it or I can't imagine it and like
I let it happen like so I had to say
those things right so then I could begin
to bring some sense of of truth to it
you know and I think it was a long time
ago but the therapist probably said
something like okay probably sees on you
it's you let it happen it's your fault
right because you got to get at those
things so that so that one can begin to
bring into Focus what does the trauma
mean and what does it not mean I mean a
classic example is it is that what would
you say to someone else example you know
he'll say well I now how many times have
I it's just I cry if I stop and think
about it enough you just stop and talk
to someone who is sexually assaulted
through no fault of their own who comes
in and tells the story they've been
telling themselves about how it's their
fault they should have walked home a
different way they should address
differently they should have left
earlier right I wrote about it in the
book over and over and over now you have
a person who let's say you take a person
who's intelligent engage in the world
who's like capable of understanding lots
and lots and lots of things but doesn't
understand that right if it were someone
else that person would understand in a
moment that's not that person's fault
right so so what you want to do is
overcome the fact that the negative
emotions that the the hijacked emotion
systems of trauma are telling that
person a lie and they're telling them so
strongly and so
awfully so meanly that the person just
takes it inside and starts to see it as
true right so you begin to hold that up
to the light of day and again one
example could be okay so someone my
person who's coming in next has actually
been through something similar right and
can do you mind can you stay and just
tell her how it's her fault right and
like oh my God no because I could never
like then they see right and again I'm
not this is not always how you do it but
sometimes you can get a person to see
like well that would be the most
horrible
how could you do that right the person
can maybe commit they're doing it to
themselves so so you know you you begin
you begin to put words in a structure
and say okay look let's look at what's
going on inside of you like you have to
be scared of anything you're thinking
and feeling in fact the fear is in not
exposing it to the light to the light of
day that's where it gets the best of us
and now like everything is different and
whether that involves use of medications
for intrusive thoughts and and
depression or there's no medicines
needed but it's all reframing like
whatever it may be that comes next the
whole world has changed when the person
has acknowledge what's happened exposed
it to the to themselves and to trusted
others around them and begun to look at
it in some way other than the stuff in
an evil box place that the trauma
initially puts us through our the
reflexes it creates in us it's
interesting that there's power to just
saying it out loud right
it's a first saying your perception of
it out loud
other in that case that might be your
fault and then working through out loud
working through
that it may not be
any experienced therapist will tell you
will tell you this that every now and
then it will happen that someone will
come and and they'll say something
usually it's very early on in the
process they'll say something they've
never said before and they immediately
are are like in an entirely different
place and they may have been for decades
right and I can remember a person saying
that the the a coach had raped him and
just saying it this was decades before
and everything was different I'm not
saying everything is now is perfect but
his life was in a different but as soon
as he said it he could see how dare like
he thought that person did that to this
child the child was me he'd never
thought it until he said it out loud
because his mind was going over and over
with why it was his fault what he did to
deserve it how he kept going back so it
must be his fault it was in it as soon
as he put words to it he saw the truth
of it and you lose a bifurcation in the
path of life then and any therapist has
had you know stories like that which
just shows the immense power that it it
can even be that just uttering the words
makes just a Cascade of change all at
once
this is saying those words to another
human being
uh yeah it makes you wonder about that
compulsive Loop that happens in our
heads right uh until it's brought to the
surface it's so interesting entirely
non-productive the loops and sometimes
even if we put what would I say to
another let me write it down it can get
rid of those Loops in our in our brains
any even thought of outward expression
is the enemy of those internal
persecutory negative thought Loops how
do you find a good therapist
I I tend to think of uh listen I'm a fan
of podcasts I'm a fan of conversations
it feels like a re you know it's it's
like finding a good friend or something
it feels like a difficult Journey
um maybe I'm wrong in that but it just
feels like such a
it feels like a partnership a journey
together versus like some very
simple clinical procedure
well the first thing I would say is to
change the entire Paradigm like most
people like okay I need a therapist so
people feel often like they're in a
weakened position because they need you
know quote unquote a therapist then
therapists are rationed right I mean how
many Insurance panels have lists a mile
long of qualified therapists who could
be on that insurance panel but there's a
certification process like these make no
sense right the state's already
certified the person right but there's
so many barriers to entry that now we're
rationing this resource which we should
all stop and pause for a second and
think like we're okay with that as a
society and by the way everything else
is like that too when we're trying to
get help for our health so let's step
back from that for a second now it's a
resource that's not in great Supply and
then a person begins to think
you know essentially I'll take what I
can get like I've got to get somebody
and I don't know enough to know anyway
right and those are very disempowering
thoughts as opposed to saying look I'm
going to be an empowered consumer and I
want to I need to choose someone who
gets over some just some basic hurdles
of what I think a reasonable human
interaction right so like is a person
making eye contact do they seem
interested right like these are basic
points about any human interaction
including a therapist right then you can
say okay is there Word of Mouth anyone
else who has something good nothing
better than a word of mouth
recommendation from someone you trusts
right or anybody can have a good website
but you say let me look at the website
what is it saying if there is one right
does it does it resonate with me or not
right but after all of that then you go
to see the person with the idea that
you're interviewing them right the idea
that yeah I hope this person can help me
and if so great I'm with the program but
I'm thinking about it do I want this
person do I feel heard do I feel cared
for
um which doesn't mean is it easy right
it might mean is it hard and I leave and
I feel like like emotional for a couple
of days but but I see that I'm facing
new things no this process of assessment
so that one isn't settling for something
that is formulaic over package and I'm
not trying to be overly critical of
therapists I mean there are people
everywhere who do their jobs well and
people who don't do their jobs well but
most therapists are working in systems
that push against doing the job well
right because they're rationing care and
there's a lot of number of sessions and
there's enough such time before a person
can return and so often it's an uphill
battle because we're trying to be helped
within systems we've created and
tolerate that are pushing against
helping us
yeah but you know that interview process
is tricky I mean if you're in a rough
Place mentally
um just like with with any kind of
interview it's hard not to
think that a failed interaction failed
interview
uh there's there's something wrong with
you sure right there is an authority to
a therapist I think where you think like
they've got it all figured out right and
I'm a mess and therefore if there's
something off it's all my fault
all right so it's a very tricky and it's
easy to then give up and then because
it's like that's step to try to get a
therapist the first like step to get
help forget therapists like any kind of
help that's a big leap to take I guess
when you're in a rough place I agree
completely we should not make people
swim against such a strong current to
get their needs met I mean we see this
in such obvious places where you have an
elderly homebound person who can't get
their medicine because oh there's been
some change and they didn't put the new
number into the form or Lord knows what
I mean it's it's incredible how we force
people to swim against strong currents
to get things that are just basic at
times for their survival and and with
that in mind I don't have a lot of
respect for where Health Care is at or
where mental health is at the the field
that I work in has accepted all sorts of
um aspects of of how things go someone
else controlling how how how long the
interaction can go on how the
interaction is bounded what can be said
and done what medicines can be
prescribed there's so many external
controls in the systems we work in that
we and I say me included like all of us
in the field
have let it get to a place where it's
obscenely difficult to get help
obscenely difficult and we should say
that's not okay I think psychiatrists
and and therapists and Master's level
social workers psychologists and you
name it I think we should all say this
is not okay and then we as a society
should be saying this is not okay
otherwise what you're saying which is I
think completely true will only become
worse as there's more and more barriers
to getting the help a person needs and
each time a person isn't helped it sets
the odds against them getting more help
I I should say here that you know when I
started working there were times I would
send people to an emergency room right
if there's some emergency you know
emergency in their mental health and
they were at risk and there were times
I'd send somebody to an emergency room
where if you stopped and looked it would
have been malpractice not to do that
right now it's not just me who who has
an incredibly High threshold for sending
someone to an emergency room because you
send someone who's in a lot of distress
and oftentimes they're sitting on a
gurney in a hallway or they're locked in
a small white room and all they had was
depression you know they're just scared
when they go in and 36 hours later oh
they're feeling a little better why
because they're desperate to get out of
there and someone sends them home I mean
so our systems have shifted so much that
we we tolerate now on mass what is
egregious to the individual
so you are a psychiatrist in terms of
doing therapy psychotherapy
what does the successful interaction
look like perhaps a fun question uh
perhaps not uh what do you think of the
psychiatrist Sean and Goodwill Hunting
played by Robin Williams
so what is the full range of interesting
interactions can there be an intimacy of
friendship a kind of
um varied interaction that kind of
Blends the lines of you know 30 minutes
session once a week or whatever versus
like a really kind of
deliberate long-term project that cares
about the well-being of a person across
the months and years
or is the what can you say about a
successful
interaction between therapist and
patient I think we're much better served
by the latter
right and again it doesn't have to be
over years we maybe person doesn't
person might need that over weeks they
might need it over months they might
need it over years but if I'm
understanding correctly you're
describing something that is like a real
human engagement yeah right and I work
in a field that for years and years and
years the patient didn't get to see the
therapist was sitting in a place sitting
behind the person right so that's not of
course the only tradition and there are
aspects of that tradition that can be
very humanized but the idea that we're
supposed to not be human I mean this
medicine is shot through with this right
that the doctor's supposed to be God and
it protects the doctor and that makes
its way into therapy and the idea of the
superiority the therapist knows more
um I mean in some ways yes but the idea
is like to know more about mechanical
things like right to know more about
like facts and knowledge not as a human
being right if we approach therapy as a
collaborative human Endeavor right where
if we're going to do it together of
course I'm going to learn from you too
right I mean we're two human beings and
we're talking about things that are deep
and personal and intimate and and I
don't want I'm not going to participate
in a way that makes it like about me as
much as it's about you but we're two
humans and what's gone on in me may have
relevance and sharing it may have
relevance and at times you doing
something back for me may have relevance
I'll give you an example of a person who
would not let me help him it was a young
man so when I was in training who was
very very sick and needed to change
certain choices and habits or he was not
going to survive and I had no ability to
help him whatsoever and I went and I saw
a supervisor who was existentially
trained where here it's different from
existentialism in the classic sense but
it's about really human connection right
and the guy was always wanting to teach
me something right because I I can get
by in Spanish but he was fluent in
Spanish and he and he wanted to eat oh
you traveled here and he'd say oh you
know a word to see if I knew and I was
always directing back to what I was
supposed to do right and the supervisor
I've never forget he said let him teach
you Spanish like okay come on so we had
a couple sessions where if you look from
the outside you say what is going on
there like right like this it was they
were Spanish lessons yeah to me right
yeah and then at some point he brought
in his mother and it was we hadn't
brought her in yet and he he was in part
showing off that he taught me something
right and I said a couple things and he
felt more powerful like he was younger
than me and he felt sick and
disempowered but he didn't feel that way
once he taught me something and we
showed it off to his mother right and
his behavior started to change he
started taking better care of himself he
could see a little more what I was
saying he's like you're a wonderful
person look you love your mother and
your aunt and they love you and like
look he could start seeing that about
himself but that came from humanness and
and I think that's the way we help
people I don't understand why we don't
do everything that way it's like right
we're two humans but if you're doing
something for me then there's something
you have an expertise and I don't that's
why you're doing it for me the reverse
could be true but it doesn't mean we're
not just two humans doing something
together and the healthcare system and
the legal system should not get in the
way of that I mean there's liability and
all these kinds of things that um
can get in the way of the humanness
I mean some of that is Justified you
have to be careful you have to make sure
there's of course you're irresponsible
but
a little too much can destroy the
humanness I'll use a weirdo usually you
say something is insane like it's not
consistent with sanity yeah and the
presence of the legal system look I'm
all for of course Physicians have to be
held we have to be responsible and
everybody makes mistakes and people to
be accountable for their mistakes
um I understand all of that but what we
see now it's so
absurd that oh like everyone is
frightened right everyone is frightened
and then just looking to like how do I
slot into the box check the check the
boxes of what I'm supposed to do and not
get in trouble you know people get sued
because someone was at that hospital and
that doctor touched their care this
happens in the VA system it happens in
other systems too so you might have
touched their care and no one's even
saying you did anything wrong but they
say the next person did oh someone
settled on your behalf and now you have
a malpractice Ding and maybe you can't
get a license somewhere else like
doctors are terrified and they're
terrified for good
they're terrified for good reason
because the same society that has given
doctors in many ways too much power over
time and and treated doctors maybe too
much like Gods now is I think enacting
some of society's anger and envy out on
the Physicians even the idea that like a
person would know what medicine like I
saw a couple TV commercials give me this
it's like it's interesting right
because even if let's say I take myself
out of it doesn't feel good obviously
but it takes about it's like wow like I
went to school for like eight years for
this and you don't even want to hear my
opinion right you're not taking good
care of yourself right it doesn't mean
you should think my opinion is gospel
because I said it but but people then
don't have an understanding of like what
is expertise what do people learn how
can people help us understand and make
better decisions it kind of goes out
with the wash and then the the the the
position of the expert I mean it's a lot
has been written about this right gets
diminished over time very much to our
own Peril and then often with aggression
in the medical world coming back towards
the alleged expert
yeah expertise is a tricky one such a
such a tricky thing because uh
coupled with expertise can the attention
is this arrogance that can come with
expertise right the arrogance can make
the the expert feel like they're more of
an expert
um and there's a vicious cycle and then
the arrogance in in the current in the
21st century especially with the
internet the arrogates can uh completely
Force the public to distrust the expert
because it all they see is to get
arrogance versus the expertise so
um ultimately you have to have I think
um the the greatest experts and Masters
I know are are the ones that have uh
complete humility right humility and
gratitude and gratitude he's just back
which is usually a really good sign that
somebody
is at the top of their field
right and they'll acknowledge that they
don't know everything right which is
hilarious right so like the the the the
the best experts I know are the ones
that will say that they don't know right
not call themselves the next person
right right it's very confusing or know
that they know a lot but don't know the
answer to this you see that a lot in
medicine that person knows they're an
expert surgeon but they also acknowledge
they don't know if this is the right
time to operate that's how you get to
the best answer instead of someone who
is an expert and always knows the answer
yeah uh if we actually rewind to uh the
beginning of our conversation we talked
about
uh you mentioned something I wanted to
return to so there's a there's layers
that are uh there's an emergent novelty
and you mentioned that we as human
beings and we introspect and our own
mind we really can't know most of it
um which of course uh makes me think of
this uh the unconscious mind
subconscious mind uh and Carl Jung how
much is hiding there in the shadows
you've you've uh investigated a lot of
uh trauma how much is there in our mind
that's not directly accessible to us
like what can you say maybe
philosophically
about how much is there
uh lurking in the jungian shadow
I think there's a tremendous amount
there but I but I wouldn't I don't
immediately go to
an ominous perspective right because if
it's lurking there right it can come get
us right and and to some extent that's
true right because either the seeds of
Evil are there if we want to plant and
nurture them you think good things can't
lurk
but you're right you're absolutely right
and the youngin Shadow is supposed to
not just be dark things it's supposed to
be everything supposed to be a lot of
positive things as well yeah right which
I think brings us to self-knowledge to
truth whereas I think the the opposite
of Envy narcissism sociopathy I I do
think is all rooted in truth it's both
the truth so the good things about us or
the ways we're not we're not blameable
for the blameworthy for the things we're
blaming ourselves for ETC but the the
self-knowledge and the truth and and
getting away from the The Reflex of
anger frustration Envy shame what I
think happens then is all of that
underneath the surface if we look at
like the Consciousness is the top of the
iceberg you know outside the top say
well outside the water so is what's
underneath like shifting and it can pull
the top under right or is it supporting
the top and and really I believe is
honesty truth self-knowledge humility
gratitude dude all this simple stuff
good mental health is always consistent
with Simplicity you know humility
gratitude or easy things to say like we
know what that is right we understand
what that is soothing Envy by having uh
immense power and subjugating others is
getting very very complicated right what
that is and how that plays out so if we
are in touch with ourselves If we're
honest with ourselves if we own what's
ours we don't try and own what's not
ours right what happens then is
something isn't waiting inside of us to
sort of jump us with some new uh fact of
self or challenge of self right then I
think what what happens are phenomena
like intrinsic learning like the way
that so much happens inside of us
automatically right how people who have
high levels of expertise know the answer
to complex questions more rapidly right
it doesn't take them longer to think
through it but they have more knowledge
to Think Through it's that more happens
rapidly and unconsciously so they know
the more comp Plex answer more quickly
and readily right and we can build that
in ourselves not just in terms of
factual knowledge but in terms of how we
respond to things right if if I make a
mistake do I respond with reflexive
shame right if I see someone has
something I'd like how do I respond
we're more in accord with ourselves and
then the automaticity in US is is
serving us better so that's in the
positive do you think do you draw some
wisdom from the the early pioneers
of psychotherapy like Freud and and
young yes that there's some repressed
uh there's some stuff to work through
that is in uh the unconscious mind
yes I think there's
always like 100 percent
of the time if you have a living human
you have things to work through in the
unconscious mind right there's too much
that goes on around us that we might
find unacceptable and suppress right
there can be
smaller but important examples right
someone who
um
feels that they're not a good enough
parent and they I don't know they
dropped the child's plate right and
um
and there's a feeling about that of
Badness in them that the person that
can't tolerate and pushes away right and
maybe they become a little bit less
confident a little bit less assertive
like those small examples are important
because they may be low valence but
there can be many many many many many
many of them right then you can look at
the opposite end of the spectrum where
someone for example feels or they have
to they're repressing their sexuality
right unconsciously there's something
that is so important to say to how a
person feels about themselves to whether
they can seek fulfillment to how they
feel about their ability to interact and
engage with others in ways that are
loving and generative over time so so
from smaller things that accumulate
often at a rapid Pace to really big
things we are pushing things into the
unconscious because they're not
acceptable and we need to explore like
why is that not accept maybe there's an
unacceptable urge because it's really
not acceptable to me right like a
violent urge maybe there's an
unacceptable urge because I'm actually
listening to the LIE Society is telling
me about what's okay and what's not okay
right so in exploring those things yes
we become happier and healthier and that
could mean if we're already happier and
happy and healthy it gets better we get
more insulated against the negative or
it can mean the person who's really
nurturing some of those seeds of of evil
and envy does that less or steps away
from it so whether it's good or it's bad
it's it's in there inside of us and we
benefit from understanding that idea of
the observing ego right like I said the
part that can stop and say hey this is
what's this is what I see what's going
on in me what have you learned about
exploring the human mind about the art
of conversation
is ultimately therapy's conversation
yeah
is there something you can put into
words yeah like what makes it a a good
conversation I think language is among
the most amazing gifts we have and it's
also one of the most like clunky routes
to misunderstanding right I think of
like there's a concept of facticity you
know things that are like I guess
necessary evils and from the religious
perspective I think is where the word
started but of language being like a
facticity right that we need to
communicate with one another we want to
communicate so we develop words and we
have these amazing brains that can have
language and that's all well and good
but our fantasy would be more like Mr
Spock right you know the Vulcan mind
meld was like I communicate with you
because we put our hands on one another
and we know you know by doing this what
what we're thinking and what we're
feeling and we won't have
misunderstanding so because I think we
can approximate that we can come kind of
close with language right or we can be
so far away from it that we can say the
same word and of opposite meanings and
have it generate immediate animosity
right that we need to be very very
careful with language with communication
with conversations and I've come to
understand that much much more as I've
gotten older both in terms of how
hurtful
um you know Reckless speeches which is
why I'm horrified by so much of what we
see in our political discourse right the
slurs the negativity that's attached to
something to some word you know how one
can utter something and it can go into
another person just into the ear but
then go through so many parts of the
meaning of the brain that that person
feels a pervasive sense of shame or
beleagueredness right so yes Reckless
language absolutely hurts people and we
see that all the time in ways that I
think are just atrocious and also how
bad miscommunication
harmless I mean I I really learned that
through a lot of different ways but in
the work as a therapist of like really
wanting to make sure that I'm really
understanding you and you're really
understanding me and a lot of work goes
into that communication I think people
we can get into a rhythm of it and then
it happens more easily but I think it's
it it's like it's a life and death
difference at times you know a lot of
times right in the world around us
between clear and accurate communication
just so I said a word because like I
think you know what I mean or something
like that yeah so to that I mean there's
the the uh Camu quote that I like as
much unhappiness is coming to the world
because of things left unsaid
so that has to do with the clear
communication
but there's also um
a dance
to a conversation a a poetry to it there
is ambiguity to language and if you have
a kind of awareness of that ambiguity
and you play with it that's what wit and
humor come in that's allows you to sneak
up to difficult topics without uh sort
of trampling on them I don't know uh
there there's an art to it as wealth
um there's an art to the silence you
know uh just allowing both human beings
one of the most intimate things you can
share with a human being is silence yeah
that's communication it's it's a
different communication but it ties more
powerful yeah giving a person space
right to uh accumulate to integrate to
make sense of their thoughts enough to
say a word maybe a memory is spark so
they can think about that memory and uh
like process that memory so it's not
just words sorry it's not just words
right because now you're talking about
communication as it's body language it's
you know it's expressions of empathy
it's movements it's pauses right like
the communication process is very very
complicated and and deep yeah and some
of that is building trust but also
challenging a person I wonder about that
whole process with uh with strangers for
example
uh how you do that successfully like you
and I just met uh today
but I think
a lot of our interaction is very free we
can get to know each other in any way we
want there's a few conversations that
have coming up
in general where there's a lot of other
pressures and constraints on those
conversations there's a there's a danger
to it there's risks there's the
political forces involved like what what
what from not from my perspective but
probably from my as well of how do you
say this thing what are the words that
are going to offend right and you're
learning that about a stranger at the
same time you know and you don't it's a
it's a it's an interesting dance because
you have to walk
carefully but deliberately right
carefully because uh I've I've learned
this about about myself about others
there's certain words that can trigger a
person
that that can make a person feel poorly
like
shitty about themselves
uh so you can you can push you can
challenge a person about something and
they're totally okay with it but if you
use a certain word to do it it's gonna
it's good it's maybe it maps to some
childhood thing that their father mother
used to say or something like this and
uh I mean part of the art of
conversation is actually
being a little bit free and using those
words but being extremely sensitive in
detecting when a person reacts to a
particular word and like storing that
away it's like okay then we might want
to return to that later
because there might be an interesting
that could be a tip of an iceberg that's
actually representing something
beautiful or you might want to just it's
a nothing word that you just want to
avoid because it's a distraction and so
all of that kind of has to be integrated
into the dance of language this is
really interesting especially when the
stakes are really high when you get one
conversation right we have when you sit
down you have one conversation and it
makes
the difference between like say you had
one conversation with a patient this is
the only conversation you get to help
sometimes it is the case yeah and like
this is pretty high stakes yeah oh man
yeah it's tough I guess you get over
um and like over time I guess you get uh
used to the the high stakes nature of it
when you develop an ability and all that
on skills processing right right right
all that part of the iceberg that's
underneath the surface is doing all of
that right is reading you know
behavioral cues verbal cues and and
recognizing the Primacy of emotion over
logic right if it were all logic it'd be
different okay we're gonna talk about
this thing I'll say things you say
things back even if it's politically
contentious sex okay we're just going to
talk logically but you know that's not
the case right there could be a word
that raises a certain emotion and you
know you don't want to tread there
because the emotion will color the
person's ability to engage and so you're
aware of all of this and then I think
from the perspective of all of that I
mean it's like standing on the shoulders
of your own internal giant right that
understands you know language and
emotions and body language and
Attunement to end history and triggering
and all of that and then on top of that
as you're standing up on those shoulders
you're trying to be effective right and
then I think that's where you know
Effectiveness can be unilateral or it
can be together I mean I think some of
what emerged
from Victor Frankel's writing after the
second world war was how much a shared
humanness means to us how much of that
can be an incentive for survival beyond
all others right so so the idea of are
we doing something if we're
communicating unilateral like I want
information from you or I want you to do
a certain thing when we're done talking
right right it can be done communicating
that's a very unilateral type of
Effectiveness which can make sense
sometimes I want information out of a
patient because I want to know what to
do next right so it doesn't have to
always be negative but it can also be a
tool of manipulation right if someone
would say coming from Envy or narcissism
I want to communicate in with you in a
way that makes you do what I want you to
do right different from that is where
it's a shared communication where you
know there's like an umbrella so to
speak over us and we're doing something
that we can all that can only happen
together because we're us we're the each
person right and we come together to do
something that's a shared Effectiveness
like I think we're doing now like
elucidating and pursuing thoughts and
getting ideas out and I think the best
situations are shared Effectiveness
situations because you call upon the
resourcefulness and the internal
resources of both people but you uh
especially with strangers especially
when it's not labeled the therapy
session
um you kind of actually stumble into
that
Cooperative state
like uh
you have to organically
develop a trust together
and almost Lose Yourself it's ultimately
I do I think you put it really nice I
think successful conversations even when
it's with uh like even if it's like with
world leaders or logicians people that
operate in the space of reason the most
successful conversation will ultimately
be in the layer in the in the landscape
of emotion like that's where the
interesting stuff will happen that's
where you'll discover anything and
that's where you get to actually meet to
start getting an understanding of each
other what you actually mean even by the
the statements that are supposed to be
kind of uh rationally based it's it's
right it's like you lose yourself you
lose yourself in the way you do when
you're uh when you're children and
you're just not shooting the [__] about
whatever topic and you just forget
yourself again
right yeah well you kind of
plug into the unconscious mind a little
bit and you get to speak maybe
indirectly but to the things that really
drive you to the thing that really to
the things to the emotions I suppose
that
underlie your world view I feel like
that that's where productive
conversations can happen whether it's a
patient or just a stranger you're
talking to uh at a bar about geopolitics
uh you mentioned Victor Frankel uh what
what do you make of his work man search
for meaning what are the the lessons you
draw from his work of him as a
psychologist but also from that a very
powerful work that reflects on his
experience in a in a in a Nazi
concentration camp yeah
I think that
it was
almost a profound reinvention of
humanness right after something so
awful so Bleak and so despairing to
speak Anew about
shared humanness human connection yeah
meaning compassion
that I think it was an intellectual
direction that that was adorned with all
the emotions that we need to Adorn the
logic with in order to make real change
in the world and I think that his work
is has fueled you know so many branches
have come from you know from his work
existential Psychotherapy and its place
in in helping human activities today
right
um a a trend away from the idea that
that we're all quite isolated and that
what's going on between us is all very
transactional right I'm putting
something out and you take it in you put
something out I take it in right the
idea no there's a difference there's a
shared humanness that creates a meaning
beyond the transaction kind of like you
were just saying The Logical stuff isn't
really that interesting because you know
the logic is there's an answer to
whatever logic is we can do math right
it's it's where does the the surprises
come in right either in terms of of
wonderful Behavior or destructive
Behavior right they're coming from
people's emotions so that's what we want
to understand and that occurs in the
context of a person and other humans you
know even if it's the conception of
someone and all and other humans as
enemy you know or it's the conception of
of two people uh sitting together the
idea that there's a shared humanness and
it's not all transactional and that he
could take that out of you know the the
a pinnacle of of human tragedy and
utilize it in a way that informs us
being better as a species going forward
I think is really Monumental what do you
think uh is the role of emotion in the
human mind
in The Human Condition because you've uh
we've talked several times in different
ways that emotion matters and it's a big
part of Who We Are
but
why is it there why is it useful what's
good about it it
will almost said it's almost like a
negative thing that we just have to live
with
but why is it also maybe a beautiful
thing yeah well I think he said what's
the role of emotion emotion is the king
if we want to use that analogy it's the
CEO if you want to use that analogy
right emotion rules rules all we're
taught that we're logical creatures but
we have innumerable pieces of data even
over the course of just a day let alone
a human experience to tell us that is
not the truth is it ever logical to to
run into a burning building
no right I mean Elijah's never going to
tell when to do that okay someone you
love is in the building the person's
already sprinted halfway to the building
right emotion rules us and so and so the
thought
a thought is some of that is
evolutionary right that strong negative
emotion stays with us very very
profoundly right so example I'll give is
if we're hunter-gatherers and like I
find a new berry and it tastes good and
it seems nutritious and then and it is
right everybody I think it's fine it'd
be good to remember that right but if I
find a new berry and it tastes good and
it seems nutritious and we both eat it
and almost die of sickness we better
remember that right so that so so the
Primacy of emotion is in us for for
reasons that are about survival that the
emotion of it's my child in that
building or my loved one is why I don't
give a damn about logic and run into the
building right the emotion of I thought
that was good and I got really sick and
I better never forget it is also about
survival and the same applies to humans
if if we're from different tribes back
then and in my tribe when you put your
hand out it's a greeting in your tribe
if I if someone puts their hand out it
means hey I'm going to attack you and
take your stuff
but then I put my hand out and you slug
me right then it's like I better
remember that right but you see how that
can lead into you know our our the
constructs around that I say oh people
in your tribe are violent right they're
right we start then to make stories
around that but the Primacy of emotion
whether it's berries or it's humans who
might threaten us or it's humans we love
I I think it's it's hard to to even look
at the anthropological psychological
literature to look at what's out there
and I think the face validity not to
that that's part of survival right it's
part of survival it's so cool that you
get also things like love which are not
often rational or grounded in logic and
so on if you if you look like sort of
from a transactional perspective
a lot of times falling in love or
whether it's with friends or uh
friendship or romantic love it doesn't
really make sense I'm still don't I'm
not I'm still not sure what the hell it
is because like I mean it uh it's the
thing that it's one of the things or
love for your kids when they're born
right like that love the the the the the
parental love
um what is that that's so cool that we
get to have like if you're looking for
the in the menu of items they give life
meaning that seems like a pretty good
one yeah so my response you said that
Gives Life Meaning my response initially
was going to be it's the meaning of life
right because saying okay emotion is
about survival that's one part right
that's and it's a very important part
right if we don't survive then then
we're not there to have emotions right
so yes it's about survival but as
important as that is that's the small
part of it right I think it is about the
meaning of life because it's about the
Beyond self and I think it relates back
to what we talked we're talking about
the very beginning and the sort of
levels of emergence right and when we
feel love we feel happiness because that
person feels happiness right there's
something that's so generative so
creative about that like we we want to
bring order to things and we we you know
happiness is consistent with Simplicity
right if we're healthy there's nothing
negative to say about our health right
if we have health problems there's a lot
to say right and it's it's emotion that
pushes us towards the the goodness that
I think makes all the meaning for us I
mean it's interesting I actually I was
wondering your your thoughts about this
as a scientist right because we we
accept it by and large that we have free
will right we deal with free will but
then we get upset that there's not
Justice right so but how is it like if
we have free will I could act in an
unjust way and then you're surprised or
you know Vice versa's like why right we
we have these thoughts because I think
because we're we're rooted we want logic
to rule like there's a way which I can
understand logic I can manage it I can
manipulate it we sort of want it to be
that way so then we we glorify logic and
then we misapply it like ideas like oh I
know we have free will but I'm now you
know shaking my fist at the heavens
because there's no justice right and I
think maybe what we're looking for is we
should go back and look at the Givens
like why is there there's only goodness
if there's Justice I mean that doesn't
make I I think the goodness why is the
goodness have to be tied to that right
maybe it goes back to the counter
entropy and the fact that when there is
something there is not nothing right and
where there is something there can be
awareness there can be goodness there
can be compassion right is it that that
that what's really going on is not about
Justice yes we have free will but it's
that goodness creating Shoring up making
better that is
the meaning that is the good right and
that the evil is the destruction as
evidenced by the fact that it's over
determined probably a million times that
we're in this anti-current of counter
entropy and we could destroy that quite
readily right and and then we're
nothingness like like everything else
that we know of that's not us that
doesn't have the ability to do something
that's creative or constructive I mean I
think that that's
the answer and I think that our science
really tells us that that's the answer
and I think it beckons us with ideas
like we know that things happen outside
of space and time right I mean they're
physics experiments right like we know
this from the science of it yet we don't
stop and look and say wait is that the
magic of the idea Einstein said God
doesn't play dice with the Universe I
think okay maybe
God doesn't play dice with the universe
that Quantum and determinacy and all of
that is not just a flip of the coin so
to speak but maybe it's in that
indeterminacy that we're given the
opportunity to assert ourselves right to
make something one way or another you
know maybe it's not God playing dice
with the universe but it's God loading
the dice in our favor if we'll only
listen to truth the truth that being
destructive doesn't help pursue anything
even in the person who thinks it will
for themselves and that creativity and
generativeness and kindness and
compassion like this is doesn't that
seem sort of analogous to the Eddie
current of counter entropy that has us
here in the first place and I think
that's where I I pin meaning and that
meaning then going back to the initial
question right is is generated in us
through emotion through what we feel
that leads us to feel something that is
mysterious I don't know why I feel it
yeah in some sense the motion is the
kind of the fuel of that creative
imperative we have but if you step back
and look at the tapestry a little bit
it does seem that the destruction the
creation of the destruction or the yin
and yang of of life that it all works
only if
the the the main engine is towards
creativity but uh destruction also
makes way for new things
so that's the
this kind of struggle it seems like life
is the struggle between the different
forces that make up the individual human
they make up Society all this tensions
are necessary for growth for development
this kind of uh inner conflict and outer
conflict are necessary for growth it's
not just the
I mean in some sense it's from the logic
aspect you kind of want everything to be
perfect and and just for nobody to
suffer for everything to be perfect but
just like we talked about with trauma
just seems like it's such a big giant
mess what is it Bukowski said uh fine
would you love and let it kill you uh
there's there's some aspect of uh the
negative aspect of passion and pursuit
and Obsession and the the the the the
turmoil of the pursuit of uh of
Happiness of the the creative Pursuits
and all of that I mean I mean that's
part of life as well that's and I don't
know what to do with that
um from an individual perspective in
terms of figuring out how to how do you
live a good life how do you live a
healthy life because it does seem a bit
of hardship or sometimes a lot of
hardship
I can make a pretty interesting life I
think it brings us back to the to the
discussion that we're having sort of
before about like what does it mean like
the challenges of trauma right and of
overcoming and I think here we gotta be
and careful with the language right
because I I would then say let's take
destruction right and and separate it
into two things right like one is you
say destruction is like the the breaking
down the tearing down of something right
versus
a process that has malice in it right so
just like when we were talking about uh
trauma and and um no setbacks things to
overcome and we'd say okay if you say
Hey you have it harder than the next
person and you have more to overcome or
someone put a barrier in front of you
for you to overcome that there can be a
lot of growth in that including the
times when you don't know if you gosh
can I do this right can I get over it
right if you're saying like that's that
could be that's Challenge and and
something to overcome that's very
positive but we're saying but there's no
benefit of like throwing a racial slur
in there right we're saying because
that's all bad like that's not even the
princess I'm I'm angry about that I'm
going to overcome that it's like that
didn't need to be that didn't make
anything better if the person sees that
and says I'm gonna I'm gonna overcome
that it makes things less worse right
right is it but there's no there's no
good to something that's that's created
as destructive when we look at forest
fires like look controlled Burns he said
there's a forest burning down but that's
okay there's some this there's some
weakness destruction there there's a
tearing down there but it's in the
service of the next fire not running
through the community you know the town
that's on the other side of it that's
very different than a forest fire say
started by arson yeah right so you might
say they're both tearing down they're
tearing down of the forest but one is in
the service of goodness even though it's
hurting the animals and the plants it's
not all good right but but it's in the
service of something as opposed to
something else that's wantonly
destructive I think there's no good to
the racial slur there's no good to the
arson right that's destruction in a way
that's incorporating I think the malice
of envy you know something that's really
purely if there's a yin and yang that's
the destruct that's the destructive
that's the Badness end so racial slurs
is a surface wave of a deeper thing and
so I mean this is I mean the reason I
bring that up is like all right well
like you have these discussions of
censorship like what good does allowing
racial slurs in Public Communication do
right and it's like our communication
would surely be better if we don't say
bad things to each other it's like
it seems like the truth is our
communication will be better if the
amount of bad things is a small fraction
of communication that seems to be more
true because another aspect of human
nature with power the moment you start
censoring and removing bad words that
everyone agrees are bad words
then the people on the at the top
they're doing the sensory start getting
greedy they start it starts expanding
and this is the giant mess of human
civilization where we can't the the nice
piles you created are kind of
overlapping
it's a gray area yeah I agree with it no
I agree completely that the control of
language there are slippery slopes there
I think there's a there's a very big
problem there so I agree I I think again
split parsing out the language I I'm not
saying hey we shouldn't have racial
slurs as if like let's stop saying the
words I mean the idea is the premise
behind it right like you know the the
prejudices if we could eliminate the
Prejudice behind it you know I was
struck I said I do not almost nothing
about medicine I get to medical school
and start with Anatomy right and it's
remarkable as you know to see where as
the bodies are being dissected that like
we're we're all humans like is it matter
it doesn't matter any of these things on
the outside like and that's true not
just like in our bodies but but in our
minds the part of the person that's not
there right because now we're trying to
learn from the body and you know it
shows how
ridiculous it is if you think that we're
99 Point how many nines you know percent
all alike genetically and by the way
it's only like take another tenth off
and we're all orangutans right so but
somehow we we have to see these
differences between us right and where
does that come from and I think that I
believe that all comes from Envy in that
classical sense that if I don't feel
good enough I'm going to want someone to
feel better about and so there can be
visual things that that person looks
different right or you think about the
you know the I I spent some time in
Great Britain and when there's a lot of
conflict in between Northern Ireland and
Ireland right and you thought wow
there's not there's not even a look
difference right it's the same general
you know religious umbrella same
ethnicity right but but now there's some
religious difference and I thought it's
not me trying to be denigrating you know
around the Irish conflicts like that's
human of oh there's no actual difference
between us if I don't feel good about
myself I'm gonna find one right it's
that
that I believe could go away it's driven
by maybe the trauma of just being alive
in the world and things can happen to us
but we certainly promote in the human
created trauma people feeling not good
enough finding differences there's a
place for the Envy to attach and We're
Off to the Races of you know Wars I mean
we're talking about the second world war
and we think what have we learned since
then would take us a day to map out all
the wars since then right uh let alone
for goodness sakes everything that's
sailing it right now so we're not pretty
we're not good at learning from what
seemed to be some very Salient lessons
I should mention one thing is that I
also know that you're interested in in
Russian culture a little bit
yes uh
Churchill said I cannot forecast to you
the action of Russia uh it is a riddle
wrapped in a mystery inside an enigma so
uh what do you are some interesting
differences between uh so this this
eastern part of the world of Russia
Ukraine the Slavic countries the former
Soviet Union all of that versus sort of
the U.S culture what stands out to you
from the literature from the music from
the science all that kind of stuff I
think there's so much
intensity
intensity and and I guess I would say
fearlessness of expression that I see in
the islavic culture maybe so maybe it's
across cultures because there's a
different way that expression occurs we
say like oh it's different and the the
French then the Spanish or is different
than in parts of Africa and I think when
you when you take that part of the world
for whatever reason and maybe it's just
totally random or maybe it's you know
it's aspects of geography and experience
and migration but there's such an
intensity and and I remember like
listening to Tchaikovsky you know very
early on maybe not for the very first
time early on in my life or reading
Dostoyevsky and and feeling like oh like
dostoyevsky's a willingness his ability
and his willingness to express and
create such powerful aberrant states of
Human Experience
um Tchaikovsky in his music the depths
of suffering think that it expresses has
always stood out to me
um
as a way that like with the if if that's
like the brightest light so to speak
communicating information that that's a
place to look and it's also a place that
resonated with me so strongly because I
think for some people who are
informative years and having very
difficult feelings right of like a depth
of feeling of like fear and how's the
world going to be am I going to be
annihilated am I what do I even want
what do I feel inside of me to to
encounter that being expressed so
intensely
um I found to be very very moving uh so
I don't know if that's a good answer or
not but I think there's an intensity of
expression and a fearlessness you know
Dostoyevsky wrote about terrible things
you know what what happens in the person
is there a person who is brilliant
intellectually and very persuasive and
very capable of being effective who also
just chooses to be a child rapist right
I mean he wrote about that he wrote
about the truths of this is what we can
be as human and I think there's so many
lessons including the truth like people
will tend to think oh Evil's not very
bright or not very intelligent that's a
way to let evil propagate right evil can
be effective and attractive and
um very compelling but evil nonetheless
and I just think there's a Fearless
willingness to to look at that and to
describe it that I see primarily I've
studied in in Russian culture
yeah the The Fearless exploration of
this whole human drama definitely does
the yes gain others since in the 20th
century in the 19th century have done an
incredible job of that some of that just
like you said is the language the
culture I think that intense Romanticism
is there that is almost an over dramatic
um exploration of of uh Human Nature
it can err on the side or a falter when
it goes into a kind of cynical view of
life you know life is suffering I think
that also has to do with the way you
deal with the trauma of the world wars
and so on this is something the
different nations throughout Europe had
to deal with that in different ways uh
some of them have channeled into envy
and resentments some of them channeled
into a kind of nihilism or a cynicism
and
ultimately the intensity of feeling is
there which is sort of interesting
um to see and interesting how that
manifests itself in the kind of uh in in
the kind of governments it builds up you
know there's there's more
um authoritarianism in that part of the
world right uh versus the Western world
that's more focused on the individual
versus the collective and uh when more
focused on the individual you have a
propensity to Value individual rights
with democracy and so on it's
interesting to watch and yeah to
reconstruct how that all came to be is
it uh is it in the blood is it in the
mind is it in some kind of thing that uh
more ethereal a collective set of ideas
that we pass from Generation generation
right uh between each other sort of the
collective of it yeah it's it's
fascinating to see
um but now reinvigorated because there's
conflict in that part of the world
you've also uh thought about the Cold
War what lessons about the human mind
about Psychiatry psychology
and about looking at the Cold War
can we take forward in the 21st century
so that we can avoid
World War III right a major cold or hot
war in the 21st century
well I think unspoken animosities are
very
very very dangerous I mean right it was
a cold war there was there was was
fighting through proxies right the
superpowers were fighting uh surrogate
Wars through proxies which of course in
and of itself causes immense suffering
but there's it's the becomes the
opposite of an exchange of ideas or an
exchange of thought you know I remember
even the Chris Jeff right not believing
that the kitchen could look like it did
at the world's fair right and you know
and and some of the misconceptions here
of like what things were like in Russia
right it was an utter it was a thought
that those other people are not actually
people right there's a there's an enemy
Society of evil which then paints with a
broad brush in a way that makes it easy
too easy for the Cold War for war to go
from being cold right to having boiling
over into utter destruction and you know
I wrote it was it was really a true
story that when I
um was in it was still this Soviet Union
but it was right around the time of the
Soviet Union coming to an end and and
and had gone on a a trip for students
from uh from England and we got to go
places that people like hadn't gone you
know it would be foreigners had gone in
many many years it was just kind of the
right timing to experience that and like
it really is true that someone said on
short notice to these poor kids that
that like these group of Americans were
coming and I have a picture somewhere of
the kid in a gas mask like they went
under their desks and put on a gas mask
and they thought right that's what I
mean that's what
yeah they're taught to think about us
and we're taught to think about them and
like now we now we're back in US them
right when you know we're all trying to
survive and we're all such you know
human life is so
um delicate right you know let alone
human happiness and we make these
divisions and we create this aggression
and latent aggression during the Cold
War we developed right the ability to
destroy the Earth right and then just
sat looking at one another you know with
it with further growing misunderstanding
and the opportunity for the proxy fights
like rather say the Cuban Missile Crisis
which I know wasn't a war but it's an
aspect of that right where we just we
have ourselves wildly you know at risk
of Destruction
without any Mutual understanding and
again I would argue that that is the
opposite of the counter entropy right
like we are setting everything up for
Less lack of communication lack of
understanding how do those feelings of
love and and shared humanness happen uh
they don't right if you separate people
and then we push ourselves more and more
and more towards reinstating the state
of entropy that's present in the rest of
the universe
what advice would you give to young
people
um that are fighting entropy with all
their might
so uh
young people and and people that are
wondering how to find a way in life what
advice would you give
um how to have a career how to have a
life they can be proud of
I think
starting off with the first principles
okay what are my values right how do I
want to live life because you know I'm
in my early 50s and when I was a kid you
know we waited for the the newspaper
came in the afternoon and then you know
and then we'd see something okay what's
going on in the world we learned
something I'd get the West Coast
baseball scores right right and and
learn about oh here's what happened in
different parts of the world and by and
large I and everyone else there adult or
child were like living in a reality that
was largely our conception was largely
what was around us right and now in many
ways it is I'm not saying it's entirely
negative of course that we have more
information we can sort of think
globally so to speak right but the other
side of that is so much of the world's
problems are are on us all the time
right like here's this awful thing that
happened how many awful things happen
each day and they're right in front of
us and there's such an immediacy to it
all that I think it can be it can like
paralyze this with error right and and
for someone who's who's young and trying
to make their ways like how do you
figure your way out in this world that
your word isn't even going to exist
right and then you see how profling it
the the generations before you are right
in so many ways and there can become I
think a push towards extremes either
nihilism or I'm gonna I'm gonna change
everything right and and it's like how
about let's start from how do I want to
behave in my own Community right which
starts with like I don't want to behave
in my household right what kind of
neighbor do I want to be I mean it might
seem like things like that are
till you're small in comparison to the
big things but I don't think they are I
think that's how you know that's how we
start building foundations that lets us
tackle the big things and then I do find
myself saying what I'm working with
sometimes doing therapy with younger
people of helping them kind of bring
back their thoughts their strivings
their decisions more to themselves and
living with and around themselves more
instead of in something that becomes
very
theoretical and therefore very
threatening and unnerving so focusing on
the people around them taking one small
step at a time to form deeper
connections to build something locally
yeah how do I want to be today if I go
into the grocery store and the person in
front of me drops something you know I
can I can scout because you know because
I'm in a rush right and I could be like
that right I can be like that I've been
that way many many times in my life
right and it's never done anyone a damn
bit of good including me right or I can
realize like the 10 seconds aren't going
to matter can I help pick that thing up
or just smiling these are the seemingly
small things that I think make the tenor
of Our Lives yeah I I moved uh I think I
mentioned you offline uh one of the
really the main reason I moved to Austin
Texas
I just remember deciding it when I went
to Walmart and a lady said
uh you look handsome in that tie or in
that suit and tie whatever
like I don't think anyone's ever said
older lady she was very sweet there's
kindness in her eyes she said that I
don't think anyone ever said anything
like that to me in my entire life and it
was just
I don't know it was like wow there's
kindness in this world I know this
sounds ridiculous but like it does not
sound ridiculous it's like those you
could be that for somebody
you go go walk around in Walmart right
the thing that you remember that yeah
and and it's it's pivotal you're citing
it as hey that was a big part of me
moving here something with the branch
point in your life that comes from the
Simple Kindness right of a person who
had goodness to give yeah right and
wasn't scared that you're going to be
upset by it or what right the rest right
right she probably didn't have the the
thought that you could be a sailing
right probably she looks She's Got
goodness to give it's simple to give it
it's that simple and it's and it's
beautiful and it's worth more to you
than like how many studies would be on
where's the right to live or this and
that none of that matters that mattered
was just that the freedom to be kind and
that's emotion that's not logic at all
that's that's purely just human emotion
and a little bit of humanness that that
little bit of connection
and then uh that's what makes life great
which is why it's not a bad idea right
that you you moved here that way instead
of one could say well
I can't believe you did that instead of
looking at all the data and hiring
Consultants of what's the best place to
live but that would be wrong right like
you you made a good decision right like
that was good data it was impactful Data
even in your thoughts about how you're
happy living here right it's not that oh
you discount you shortchange yourself by
not relying on all the logic right you
felt something about the place and you
felt it as symbolized in a person and
that made the choice for you it's a
balance of course but uh you also have
to know yourself a little bit sometimes
you can find stability and comfort and
kind of reasoning things out a little
bit uh maybe as uh people close to me
have sometimes criticized and that I'm a
little bit too romantic where I'll just
follow the feeling
and you know life you know there's
physics right there's a reality to this
world right and sometimes
um reality doesn't allow you to flourish
if you just follow your feelings but
there's a dance there and uh yes
happiness is ultimately found in that
landscape of feeling and emotion versus
facts
and reason and logic as you said have
their place right everything yeah they
have their place but they're not the
be-all and end-all
you're an incredible person Andrew
huberman is a friend of yours is he said
you absolutely must talk uh called
dicerothy the the number of people you
know that are just incredible people
there's just this group of folks that uh
somehow helped each other flourish and
grew together and I'm just I'm so happy
you exist I'm so happy you're doing the
work you're doing I can't wait for your
second book thank you and thank you for
talking today this is really cool thank
you so much I'm proud to be among the
group of people that you cited uh proud
to be their friend and proud that you've
had me on today thank you so much thank
you Paul
thanks for listening to this
conversation with Paul Conte to support
this podcast please check out our
sponsors in the description and now let
me leave you with some words from Victor
Franco
everything can be taken from a man but
the last of the human freedoms to choose
one's attitude in any given set of
circumstances
thank you for listening and hope to see
you next time